Hello everybody!
Give me a sec, I was actually in the middle of writing an email.
I had to write an email to book an elevator to move in, the second move in, because like, one move in was not, one moving was not enough.
I had, well I wouldn't say I had too much stuff, but like, um, I, okay, I didn't tell you guys the story, but like, um, so I had like, so I figured, you know, I figured like, the internet stuff would take a very long time to do, because usually you, in the past,
you like, send people in, like you have to make an appointment to like a technician, and then the technician does like the thing, like you know, the beep boop boop bop bop, and then, I don't fucking know what they do.
They're like sci-fi to me.
Um, but basically, uh, so like, that's how, usually how it goes.
You make an appointment, and a technician comes in, and it's like, I'm gonna install the internet, and bring in the equipment, because I was like, oh, I don't know if, um, I don't know like, if I have the equipment for it.
So, that's how it's always been.
Um, so like, uh, so I was like, in a call with the lady, um, to be like, yeah, it never showed up.
When I registered for like, my ultra fiber, the 3000 upload download shit, like the appointment thing never showed up.
And I was super confused.
I was like, oh, maybe I just need to wait 24 hours.
So I waited 24 hours, but it still didn't show up.
So I was like, okay, that's weird.
Like, I'll just call them.
So I called them, and they were like, they're like, oh yeah, this was by the way, this was after the first move in.
So I kept my PC stuff at my old apartment, because I was like, okay, I'm gonna wait until all the, because I have like obligations to do, obviously.
Like, so I was like, alright, I'm gonna, I'm gonna like wait.
I'm gonna wait until, I'm gonna wait until like, my internet's installed, and then, and I'll move the PC over.
And so what I found out in the call, um, was that, uh, she was like, there, there's the, the equipment's in the building, in your room.
Like, in the, your, in your apartment.
And I was like, what?
Like, this is when I was like, at the old apartment.
So I was like, what do you mean?
I was like, how is that possible?
Like, I am literally the first tenant.
Like, there has, it has, because it, there hasn't been like, any other tenant before me.
I'm literally the first one.
No one has lived in this, in this apartment, except for me.
So like, um, so the lady was like, no, no, no, there, there is, there, there, it says in our files that there is, there is like, uh, there is internet already installed.
And I was like, like, it's already activated.
Because you already paid for it.
I was like, what?
So, for those who don't know, and I was so stupid, because like, by the time, like, I got all this call over, the movers had already left.
So like, I couldn't be like, hey, by the way, go grab my fucking desk.
Because the movers, by the time I did that call, um, the movers already left.
So, um, because like, the, we did two calls.
The first call, they said it was, like, it was there, but you gotta check, because like, we're not, if you're not sure, we don't know.
Because I was, I was at my old apartment, getting ready to move my stuff, and like, moving everything but my desk.
And then, when, by the time I got there, got to the new, because then they're like, okay, when you get to your new place, call, we'll call you.
Uh, we're gonna call you at this time.
And then, like, you can check.
So like, apparently, it was like, in some fucking, it was in like, a closet.
And like, there's like, a panel in a closet.
That, and when I opened it.
All the internet stuff was already connected.
Because new buildings, new buildings, have fiber already installed automatically.
Which was, I had a, it's crazy for me, because like, I didn't grow up with that.
Like, like, every building, every new building, the last couple of years, have already has like, fiber installed.
So like, you don't have to deal with that.
Like, you literally only just have to like, activate it.
Like, online.
And then you get internet.
Like, I was like, holy shit.
We don't need hover cars.
We just need the internet.
Like...
Like, the future is, who the fuck needs internet?
Like, who the fuck needs hover cars?
When I have fiber internet automatically installed in the apartment.
Um...
But yeah, like, I like, found it.
Because they're like, it's there.
So I was like, looking around the apartment.
I was like, where?
And it was like, a fucking panel hidden in like, one of the closets.
And like, I opened it and it was just cables and internet.
And like, I just needed to connect it.
I was like, because it's already activated.
So like, all I needed was like, the pa...
Like, the...
The...
The machine itself has like, the password and like, the name of the internet.
Like, thing.
And then, so I was just like, oh my god.
That's fucking crazy.
Anyway.
So, yeah.
I need to do two...
I need to do two move-ins now.
Because, um...
Because like, I have to fucking...
I have to fucking move my work desk over there.
So I have to book the elevator for the move-in.
To be sure.
Because like, last time I lied.
And they were like, oh, we don't want...
Because I was like, I can't go back.
Like, what am I going to do with all my moving equipment?
Because I can't go back.
So like, I don't want to do that again.
Because like...
I don't know if like...
I don't know if like, the other concierge...
Um...
Yes, I have like, a concierge.
No, it's not just the desk.
It's also a lot of like, clothes too.
I didn't finish packing up my clothes.
Because I was just like...
I just brought like, a bunch of clothes.
And then like...
Um...
But then I didn't bring my...
Rest of my clothes.
So I need to come back to move the clothes as well.
Um...
But yes, it's very...
Very expensive.
Uh...
Not a great time.
Which comes to my wallet.
Um...
And so like...
I have to email the concierge.
I like having...
Uh...
Well, it's like the lobby people.
Because it's more like, safety wise.
Um...
It's sort of like, safety wise for it.
I'll tell the story of why.
I like...
I like having...
Like, I like renting apartments with like, a lobby person.
I'll tell you what...
Why.
Like, when I fully...
When I fully like, move out...
There's like a...
There's like a funny story to it.
So...
Um...
But only when I fully move out.
Because then I can be like, well I don't live there anymore.
So I can talk about the story.
But...
Well wait.
Wait.
Wait until next week.
And I'll tell you the story of why I prefer that.
Like...
Um...
Alright, let's seemingly finish writing my email.
Real quick.
Alright, I need to make sure I don't read this email out loud too.
Alright, I'm almost done guys.
Alright, there you go.
Alright, I don't want to accidentally dox myself again.
Alright!
Also, another issue, why we were looping.
I did a little white lie.
I didn't actually use the bathroom.
But I didn't want you guys to judge me during the loading stream, during the intro.
It's a little white lie, okay?
It's a little white lie.
But basically...
Basically, I'm very stupid.
And apparently, I didn't pack my controller because I was like, Oh, what if I play a game that I know?
A game where I need to use my controller?
So I was like, okay, I'm going to make sure I don't pack my controller.
What I didn't realize is...
I packed my controller cable.
Because I put all the cables in one bag.
I was like, cable, cable, cable, into the Ziploc bag you go!
And I put it in the box.
So...
I didn't pack the controller!
But I packed the controller cable!
So I was trying to find another cable.
I don't even know if it'll work because I haven't tested it out yet.
But essentially, what the setup is currently...
Is that I found my PlayStation 5 controller cable.
And I Frankensteined it onto my Xbox controller.
So I don't know if it's going to work.
Because like, I don't know.
It's just cables.
Just like how you guys said, it's just RAM.
So like...
So we'll see how it goes.
I haven't tested it out yet.
Also on another note...
I feel really bad for...
For...
For Salt.
Pour one out for Salt.
Because he went fucking viral.
I did not...
I didn't expect that to happen!
And like overnight...
Overnight from one single like PC stress test stream.
Like if my PC curse wasn't so...
Wasn't so bad, we would never have this moment at all.
This...
This like...
Like one...
One of a million time moment where...
Everything has led to my boy Salt...
Getting rejected.
In sort of almost 4000 views.
Has hit one million views.
And I'm like...
Oh...
Pour one out for Salt, man.
Content gods are looking after you.
Black, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I might have...
Like a million PC issues.
But at least I can still make content.
Um...
Ash, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hi, Doki.
I'm happy to tell you I finally got your Lunar New Year Crooks done!
It came...
It came out and it looks awesome...
Awesome next to my PC.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
I'm really happy.
I'm really happy things are slowly getting shipped out as always.
I'm always happy.
That's why we haven't had any new merch in a while.
In terms of like...
I'm distributing merch.
Like personal merch.
Um...
Because like I said...
Other people are like...
The reason why we haven't got any merch like the birthday stuff or like...
Uh...
Battle Bridge stuff.
Like it's all like in the pipeline.
But I'm not releasing anything until our merch situation of shipping stuff is fully like...
Fixed.
Like...
I just want that to be like fully fixed before I do like continuous releases.
And...
Um...
Also...
I want you guys to like save your money.
Because I don't want to milk you guys.
Like I don't...
Like...
Like I want...
I want to make sure you guys have enough money for like rent and like internet.
Because you need to have a place to live to watch me.
And...
And food.
Because you need food to survive.
So you could watch me.
So like...
You know...
I want to make sure you guys save enough money for...
Being alive.
So you could still watch me.
And subscribe to me.
And then have a family.
So you can have your kids.
Watch me.
And subscribe to me.
And have your wife or husband watch me and subscribe to me.
So like I need you guys alive.
So that's why like...
We are not having like...
Not like...
That's why I'm not like having like a lot of merch releases.
Um...
Just because like I want you guys to like...
To like be able to have...
You know...
Um...
Money.
I want you guys to have an income.
So you can be alive.
Anyway.
But yes.
I was very surprised.
And um...
That it went viral.
And like honestly like what the fuck were they doing?
Talking about all of this in a public voice chat.
There is discord on comment.
That is not an excuse.
Like...
Like I don't understand.
I don't understand how they had this entire conversation.
In a public voice chat.
This is a public Apex Legends lobby.
Like why are they talking about...
Like why were they flirting?
Okay.
Well to the guy it was obviously flirting.
But to the girl they were just really good friends.
Oh god.
Oh...
Poor guy.
Oh my god.
I am glad he did not hear that.
Like...
That's...
That's why I asked that question.
When he was like...
When he was DC'd.
Because like I felt like that was gonna fucking hurt him even more.
That was gonna...
That was gonna like actually destroy him.
Oh...
He knows now.
Maybe they don't.
Maybe they are not part of that side of the internet.
Who knows?
Oh my god.
But...
You know...
I don't know if you guys heard it.
Because I was talking over it.
And like...
Because even I was shocked.
But like...
After she was like...
No.
She went...
God no.
So you didn't hear that other no.
You heard the first no.
So...
I was like...
But the second no.
Was...
God no.
So...
I was just like...
Oh my god.
That poor man.
Holy shit.
Oh...
So thank god that guy DC'd.
Before he heard that.
And that he came back before he heard her...
Heard the disgust in her voice.
Like...
Oh my god.
And the...
The...
The twist of the knife there...
Was the fact that Peter was listening in to all of this.
Because he was right next to her.
So he could literally hear her talk to him.
Like...
That's so weird.
I just...
What the...
She was like...
Peter is right next to me.
So like...
He's...
Peter is literally listening to like this entire conversation from her end.
So it's like...
I don't know...
That's just weird.
That's just so weird.
This entire situation was so fucking cringe and weird.
And then there's me.
The random person in the lobby that has to listen in to all of this.
Like...
Yeah.
I'm just a random person.
The random VTuber that's just...
There.
That has the...
The little insight into their lives.
That they put out publicly.
And I dragged you guys down with me.
So now we all know about their life.
Now we're all gonna like...
Five years later.
Down the road.
We're all gonna be thinking about...
Salt.
Sadness.
Happy死스리.
I wonder how they're doing right now.
Or like...
Are Sami and Peter still together?
Is THIS Salt...
Like...
Shadow?
Is she still trying?
I thought I was the third wheel!
I was actually the fourth wheel!
That's actually...
I think my favorite part of the conversation was that I was watching Mike.
Oh, you guys were like, I'm getting third hand embarrassment right now.
I am getting the second hand embarrassment and you guys were like, I'm getting the third hand embarrassment, man.
I didn't know we turned into a drama channel, but let's go, I suppose.
Delta, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, that's actually crazy.
I can't believe it.
Well, at least like, you know, despite my PC being an absolute fucking bitch, at least I got content.
At least I got my content.
Alright.
Alright, anyway.
God of War time.
Pew, pew, pew.
Oh wait, no.
They don't have guns.
Back then in the ancient times.
What is it?
Slash, slash, slash.
Oh, it doesn't have the same ring to it.
Alright, let me make sure that we have everything a-okay.
Give me a sec.
Let me get boy into here.
Alright, boy.
That's the only thing I know about this game.
Oh, that's not true.
I also know about the...
The threesome.
In the first God of War game.
I know about that too.
I don't know why, but that was like...
That's like it.
Cause I was way too young.
I was way too- it's in the first God of War game or something.
But there's like a scene with like some fucking- I don't know.
Some goddesses.
Yeah, the- was it a quick time event?
I was definitely way too young.
I was way too young.
It was that like- and then it was like the God of War.
And the- yes, the quick time event minigame.
In the very first God of- or was it the first or third God of War?
Whichever it was.
All of them?
Okay, all of them.
Wait, it was all of them?
Okay.
So I remember there's apparently a quick time event where you bang one of the goddesses or something.
Or multiple goddesses.
And like, I was way too young to learn about that.
But like- but like, well not that young.
But like, definitely where I was like, who the fuck?
Cause it was on like- I just- I remember because it was like- it went viral.
It should not have went viral.
Um.
It was- it should not have went viral.
But like, people were like, oh my God.
Because it was like so out there.
What the fuck, a quick time event?
When were you- what the fuck?
The betting quick time event?
Oh.
Anyway.
Obviously they- he has a son now.
So apparently one of the quick time- apparently.
So obviously he has a son now.
So I guess he failed one of the quick time events.
Um.
So now- now he has to deal with being a father.
So yeah!
Wait, I wonder why I can't- Okay, let me see if I- I'm gonna reboot this.
So I can have controller.
I actually don't- it has to be like controller.
Cause it like came out for the console.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Yeah, the quick time- quick time event game.
Failed.
Alright, let's see.
Give me a console!
Give me my controller!
I don't wanna play this on MMK.
Alright.
Guys.
Guys, this is an issue.
Because my controller is not registering.
This is- that is not good.
That's not something.
To be happy about.
Well.
Oh.
Help us build.
Guys.
Why is my controller not registering?
Maybe it's my- oh!
Maybe I disabled it!
You know what?
I could've.
Let me double check.
I need to make sure I did not disable the controller.
Alright, controller settings.
Next.
Okay.
It says I have my controller installed in there.
Alright.
Guys.
Okay.
We're gonna- maybe we gotta- we gotta go to the settings!
Maybe like in the settings.
There you go.
Okay.
Maybe like in the settings.
Oh.
Why am I- why am I laggy?
What the fuck is going- I have 64 gigabytes of RAM.
Like.
What's going on?
What's- what's going on?
Okay.
What's going on?
Oh!
100% CPU!
100%!
Okay.
Let's- gameplay.
Okay, guys.
We are at 100% CPU.
That's not good.
I feel like that is not good at all.
So let's... um... let's figure this out.
Ow... I'm a little worried right now.
I'm a little worried.
Guys... give me controller.
Why can't I use controller?
I don't understand!
Turn on DLSS.
Okay, give me a sec.
Original... though...
But... it's original!
How?
You turn off the AMD off?
Oh!
Okay.
Performance quality... off.
There we go.
Sorry.
Is that better?
Is that...
Did we do it?
Did...
It's still at 100.
I don't feel very...
I don't feel very confident right now.
From 5 to 7.
Oh!
It feels a little better.
It feels better.
Alright.
We're doing it.
We're...
We're slowly...
Okay.
FPS limit 120.
Zero motion blur.
That's good.
That's very good.
Um...
I think...
I don't like...
Oh!
It's at 90%!
I mean, 90% CPU sounds...
Sounds a lot better.
So...
I don't like that.
The 90% makes me feel a lot nicer.
Oh my god.
Alright.
That's good.
Okay.
Alright.
Nice.
I'm a bit sad that I can't play this on the controller, right?
Is it because I have a PlayStation...
Okay.
I'm gonna get my PlayStation 5 controller.
Give me a sec.
Maybe it's because this game is for PlayStation.
I mean, Sony.
Sony?
Alright.
I'm dead.
Please!
I just wanna yell, boy!
Just like Sean!
Alright.
Let's see.
It says, press B.
But like...
It's not registering it.
Which is awkward.
Okay.
Yeah.
It works.
It's because...
You have to play...
You have to...
Sony was like, no, no, no.
Get that Microsoft dog shit out of here.
Yeah.
They're like, no, no, no, no.
We know you're using Microsoft on our Sony game.
How fucking dare you?
Alright.
I'm gonna make sure everything is...
Okay.
Original.
Yes.
Photo mode.
View controllers.
Gameplay.
Tutorial mode.
Default.
Okay.
I don't like controller vibrations that much.
So...
We'll do that.
Quick turn.
HUD.
Camera.
We'll do...
Minimal camera shake.
It's like...
Aim assist!
Fuck yeah!
Okay.
Audio.
Alright.
As always...
We'll turn down the music just a little bit.
Because...
We need the dialogue.
And then we'll also do that too.
And then...
On.
There we go.
We're good.
Are we good to go?
Oh!
I can't even hear the audio!
Oh my god!
It's like...
On my...
Fucking...
Give me a sec.
My...
The audio went to my...
My controller.
The audio went to my controller!
Give me a sec.
I'm like...
What the fuck?
I can't hear!
It literally went to my controller!
Alright.
There we go.
That should be good.
Is it on system?
Yeah.
Do I hear anything?
Wait.
Why don't I hear anything?
It should be on my system!
Oh my god.
Oh, there we go.
I have to close it.
Alright.
We're good.
New game.
Give me a balance.
Give me a challenge.
We want some more.
You know what?
Wait.
No.
God of War is...
Wait.
But it's not...
You don't shoot your gun.
Um...
We don't...
You don't shoot your...
There's no guns in God of War.
Challenge is actually pretty hard.
That's...
That's enough.
We're not doing...
I've never played God of War before!
There's no gun in God of War!
If there were guns in God of War...
I would easily pick God of War.
But he...
Can you tell?
He doesn't carry a gun!
He's thinking about the time he lost the QuickTime event.
And now he's fucking...
Um...
Now he has to take care of a child.
It's not Gun of War.
It's...
He has an axe!
Alright.
Boom.
Get down here.
You know what's...
It sucks.
Because my windows deactivated itself.
I have activate windows on the far...
Like bottom right.
Boom.
Oh, game is a bit low?
Don't worry.
I'll turn it up.
Sorry.
Just stay there for a little bit, sir.
Just...
Fuck trees!
That's right, Mr. Beast.
You're getting canceled.
So now I'm gonna cut down all the trees I planted.
I'm taking it all back.
Whoa.
Is he okay?
We're undoing...
We're undoing the trees.
I found some.
Oh my god.
No, the child.
Get in the boat, boy.
Haha!
He said the thing!
He really did get more depressed after having a kid.
Holy shit.
He's carrying all of that himself?
Start the boy counting.
Alright.
Audio is a bit still.
A bit low.
Okay.
Oh shit.
What the fuck?
Where...
Oh, it's Midgard!
That's not what I want to do.
Where am I?
Where's the settings?
Why did this...
Okay.
Settings.
Audio.
Okay.
I'll turn up the music a little...
More.
Alright.
Alright, boy!
Let's go to your mother?
Or my single father?
Oh!
That means I'm not a deadbeat!
I'm not a deadbeat father.
No!
That boy is going to grow up with mommy issues.
Single father and ready to mingle?
Oh my god, he's a doof!
Recently single father.
Alright boy, your mother left you because she didn't want you anymore.
So I gotta take care of you.
You know, you can have multiple mommies if you want.
God of War 1-3 did a lot for me.
Wait, how is it different?
It's Midgard.
It's less godly, that's for sure.
Okay guys, I really do not like the vibrations.
Like, every time I row the fucking boat, it vibrates.
Like, get that out of here.
Get that out of here.
Like, I do not need the controller.
To vibrate every fucking time I row the boat.
Like, what is it trying to do?
How is this immersion?
The boat doesn't vibrate!
Okay, bring up overall sound.
Okay.
Ooh, hello tree.
Daniel Busetti.
Oh, you guys don't see that.
I like how it took me, like, fucking eight chops to chop the tree down.
But I can literally carry this entire tree.
Like, how fucking...
I don't know, what is this, like, strength?
Can I walk?
Can I run?
No.
Yes, this is my first game of the franchise.
I've never played God of War before.
Uh...
Thank you for the super chat, Funels.
Thank you, thank you.
So I have no knowledge of anything.
Strength, yes.
Alright.
Eight chops is pretty...
Eight chops?
But he can just carry this entire tree!
If he can carry the entire tree, he can chop a tree down after three.
Okay, we might need to do some more stuff to lower the CPU, if you guys have any ideas.
Whoa.
Is that my log cabin?
Do we live here?
Oh
my god, Burrito!
Thank you for the Akka soup!
Oh my god, is that, like, my wife?
Is he...
Is that... Is that his mom?
The fuck is...
The fuck is she?
Well, there do I see my mother.
Well, there do I see my father.
Oh!
Oh my god, he's gonna grow up with so many issues.
Well, there do they call to me.
How did she die?
Oh my god.
Well, there do they call to me.
He's gonna have so many issues.
She's ready.
Their voices is quiet?
Okay, I'll turn it up even more later.
Look, this is a very emotional scene and I don't wanna like, go to the settings page while we're carrying our dead wife.
She failed her own quick time events.
Oh, they're gonna burn her!
Well, I have like, no emotional attachments here because I don't even know what she looks like, so...
I have like, no background of her.
Chris, she just exists to be dead.
What the fuck are you doing?
Fire is hot?
Did your mom didn't teach you that?
This is why she's dead.
I'm sorry.
This knife...
It was hers.
Now it is yours.
She taught you to hunt.
She knew.
Shall we?
Now?
Stab him!
Stab your father!
Wait, is he actually gonna stab me?
What you got there?
A knife!
No!
It's not a knife.
What are we hunting?
You are hunting...
Which way?
In the direction of deer.
What the fuck does that mean?
Okay...
Artie's like...
What the fuck is in the direction of deer?
Like, deer is everywhere?
Even Artie's like, what the fuck do you mean?
Stop talking in riddles!
Okay, let me...
Boost up the volume.
A bit more, too.
All right.
All right, guys.
We're gonna play a little game.
How do I reduce CPU?
Let's play a little game, everybody.
How do I reduce the CPU?
This is what happens when I swap to AMD from Intel.
Okay.
V-Sync is off.
Wait.
Turn off DLSS.
All right.
We're gonna turn off DLSS.
And then...
There's low shadows?
The fuck do you mean low shadows?
Yeah.
We're in AMD territories now.
Because Intel is dying at the moment.
Framerate down.
Okay.
I am willing to...
I'm willing to negotiate and we'll make it 100.
I'm willing to negotiate, guys.
This is dead space all over again.
But, like, you don't understand.
I cannot live...
I cannot live under 100 frames.
I will actually die.
My body will wither away if you make me go below 100.
All right.
Custom.
We don't need shadows.
Like, what the fuck do we need shadows for?
What...
Do we need a reflection?
What if I don't...
Actually, no.
The reflections look nice.
The reflections actually look nice.
Okay.
Let's see.
Look.
My eyes...
If I go...
If my eyes go below 100 frames, I will go blind.
Like, my eyes are too...
My eyes...
My eyes have been spoiled for way too long to go beyond...
To go below 100.
I will actually go blind.
And if I cannot see, then what's the point anymore?
All right.
Here we go.
Let's see.
100 frames.
This is my limit.
All right.
There we go.
Uh...
We should...
I don't know if we're gonna be okay, but, like...
There we go.
All right.
Here we go, boy.
What did you find, boy?
What are these?
What tracks are these?
I don't need to access camera settings.
That a boy.
Where are we going?
Boy.
Oh, boy.
Oh, hey, what's this?
Lost and found?
A new artifact?
What's this?
We found this little toy near the house.
I used to have one like it.
I think it may be part of a set.
If we find more, they may be worth something.
XP!
I like XP.
Oh, a chest!
Oh, I got a hack silver.
Whatever that is.
Oh, okay, we don't have to blast it.
Okay, I'll turn down the sound effects.
Let me know what you think, sound guy, because I did adjust it a lot.
After.
All right, I'll put it at 72.
That's how real men open.
What, you don't smash it?
Using keys are for pussies.
People are like, we gotta find a key.
Why find a key?
A chest is made of wood.
Just smash the chest.
Throw a chest at a really high building, and then smash it.
I mean, I don't know if the items are...
I don't know if the items are gonna be smashed, but like, at least the box is gone.
Oh, nice.
And destroy.
That's what the chest is for.
It's gonna absorb the impact, guys.
The chest will absorb the impact, and the loot will be fine.
Trust me.
And destroy.
That's what the chest is for.
It's gonna absorb the impact, guys.
Deer!
Why is his antlers blue?
Slow down, boy.
Sorry.
You are hunting deer, not chasing it.
Oh, God, it's time to smash.
Boy, smash.
I just love how he just punches it in the center.
Oh, look, there's treasure!
Treasure!
Can I go down?
No, not yet.
I'm gonna hack silver.
I guess hack silver is like the money.
He broke our bridge.
How the fuck did he break that?
Step aside.
Am I gonna smash it?
Oh, my axe.
And then...
Oh, does it come back?
Where'd my axe go?
Oh.
What happened here?
Oh, okay.
Oh, I can recall it!
Like in...
Oh, that's cool.
I was like, what was gone forever?
Kill him?
Damn!
Bro, his mom just literally just died today.
I'll bet there's no therapy in Midgard Kateyama!
This child's not gonna get any have.
This child's gonna grow up as a serial killer, I bet you.
Oh my gosh.
This is what happens when you fail the QuickTime event.
If you didn't fail it...
You wouldn't have to deal with that.
Be better.
Oh, okay.
This guy is fucking weak.
Boom!
Oh shit!
Oh, okay.
That's fine.
Wait, this is easy.
Hey, you have a bow!
Shoot!
Oh no, I took the bow.
Sorry.
Maybe I shouldn't have took the bow.
Now this is gun of war!
Hey, I'm supposed to block?
Why block when I can do this?
Woo!
I will never learn anything else!
There we go.
I
block!
Just back away slowly!
Nice.
I like how they're like, remember to block and evade!
Will it keep going until I learn?
No.
Okay, that's good.
That's good.
That's very good.
How do I block?
Oh.
Nice.
Alright.
Guys, it's okay.
It's okay.
I will use block at another stage of my life.
Told you.
Axe of war.
I did it, guys!
I learned!
X to evade?
How the fu- Oh, like this?
Oh, this is evade.
Guys, I'll learn- I'm gonna learn it.
After.
Who needs to learn your lesson when I can just cheese it?
It's so nice.
I knew they would always be gun when I wanted it.
Meow.
Alright, any loot?
I love loot.
Might be a father now, but...
Boy, I'm gonna teach you the axe of grave robbing.
Oh.
Smash it!
Oh, I can smash this!
Find and solve three seals?
I gotta use my brain?
But what if I smash?
Oh, nice.
Okay.
That is the answer.
Thank god.
That's good to know that the answer is always smash.
Oh, there's the last one.
There you go.
Alright.
It's just smashing, but like, with different- with a different chest.
Money?
Yay!
You collected one of three Ion's apples.
Needed to increase your maximum health.
Oh, nice.
Alright.
Ion's apples are your choice of food of the gods.
Find the nine total apples in the world.
In a chest locked by magic.
Every three you collect.
Oh, I like HP.
Oh my god!
There's all the three free money!
But I guess we don't- I mean, we live in a fucking cabin, so I guess we don't need money.
Like, we're- we're- we're like, literally hermits.
We're isolated from the world.
Like, what are we gonna buy?
I don't think there's any shop nearby.
Mom's literally dead.
And it's your fault, child.
Remember that.
Wait, I don't know where to go.
Oh, that's where the deer is.
Okay, then I should go this way.
But
we please- Damn.
Forget what your mom told you.
It's loot time.
That's right, boy.
Follow the man.
You think you can- you have free will?
You think you can tell me what to do?
I am like 300,000 years old, I think.
I don't know.
Is that it?
Oh, what if I- Cut that.
Wait, there's like- you can go up.
How do I go up?
Boy, how to go up, boy.
Oh.
Up I go.
Alright.
Let's see.
And then down I go.
What is this?
Climb the chain.
Down I go.
Weeeee.
Okay.
That's right.
Boy!
Fucking help!
Use your knife!
What is the point of having your mom's shake knife if you don't shake?
Like, you're just gonna watch me do all the work?
You're never gonna grow up in this world.
They weren't mean.
They were starving.
And now we'll not starve!
That's the best part, boy!
I've always admired wolves, but the ones we've encountered attacked us on sight, which means they're probably rapid.
I guess to them we are food.
I know it's, um...
I know it's kill or be killed, but still, they're beautiful in their own way.
And killing them makes me a little sad.
Good thing father won't read this.
Oh, my boy's a fucking pussy.
Don't worry, boy.
You're gonna kill them all.
Especially if they're starving.
You think you have privacy now, boy?
Your mom is not here anymore.
And I will make sure you will not even have doors in your room.
As your father, I will come in anyway.
Because I am your father.
And what I say is law.
And now you're gonna grow up in 20 years to resent me.
And then never speak to me ever again.
But for now, I will have 20 years to do this!
Alright, let's open this grave.
Desecrate the grave!
Alright, let's see...
I guess I looted everything.
Have the wolves ever thought about climbing out of here?
There's literally nothing here.
Alright, let's see...
I think that's it.
Alright, we're gonna turn...
We're gonna turn down the sound effects...
by 10.
And then...
Boost up the overall audio a little bit more.
Alright, let me know if this is a lot better.
Audio guy.
Alright.
Toki, are you okay?
Gary, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah.
Guys, I'm a VTuber.
We're not all...
We're not okay.
If you're a VTuber...
You're already not okay.
This way, right?
Yeah, now we can go here.
I'm respecting your privacy by knocking.
But it's already my fault.
Don't worry.
Alright.
Let's see.
Guys, I don't know if you guys know this...
But even I know Kratos is not a very...
Very good guy.
Before he became a father.
Becoming a father...
Does not change who you are.
Like...
You just have a smaller version of yourself.
But like...
Becoming a father doesn't hide the shit you did...
In the first three games in the trilogy.
Like...
Alright.
Yay!
Oh, he was a father before?
Then he was always like this.
Can I have my bow back now?
He had a daughter?
What the fuck happened to her?
What...
What happened to her?
I didn't even know about the daughter.
Oh shit.
He's not...
He's...
He's not real.
He's just an illusion.
Look, you always have to test these things, guys.
You...
You always have to test it out.
I had to make sure he was real.
He's not.
He's not real.
I'm fucking going through some shit over my dead wife.
So I'm imagining about a son that we could have had.
I'm not a murderer if he never died.
That's the thing.
I know.
It was her wish.
And...
It was time.
Okay.
All right.
Enemy during combat is to play above them when they take damage or when targeted by Kratos.
You mean I never have to block again?
God, I love this game.
Yay!
Are you going to run at me?
That's right.
You can't even get close to me.
There he goes.
Easy.
Easiest game of my life.
Oh, wait.
There's more.
Oh, fuck.
It's all right.
Easiest game of my life.
This is so...
I'm setting the watch.
What do you mean?
Why give me this mechanic if I'm not going to abuse it?
Like, what do you expect?
Wait.
Can I go back?
I didn't realize that was the other...
You can headshot with that?
Oh, this changes everything.
Guys, this knowledge changes everything.
Okay.
Let's...
Just pull.
Pull.
What do I do here?
What do I hit?
This?
What am I supposed to hit?
Oh!
The glowy thing!
Sorry.
It wasn't yellow.
So, I couldn't tell.
I've been trained on yellow!
How was I supposed to know blue was it?
Like...
Okay.
Alright.
Let's open this.
Time to desecrate your grave.
They should have burned your body so it wouldn't get looted by me.
Wait.
I don't understand.
Do we go this way or this way?
Should I just leave my son?
Alright, son.
We're going to...
I'm going to go this way.
No, no, no.
You...
That's right.
You go there, little boy.
You go there.
I'm trying to figure out where they go.
Where am I?
Is that me?
And then this is...
Oh!
Okay.
Guys.
Is right side the detour?
Is right side loot?
What?
Why is there a little hole that's just you size?
Okay.
We're going to go this way for loot.
That's just your size.
Alright.
It just needs some yellow paint.
You're right, Nova.
Oh!
Jesus!
You have your...
Oh, wait.
I...
Oh, he can't hit shots yet.
Alright.
Don't worry.
I'm just going to make sure I hit you in the head.
Oh, shit!
No!
Bad dog!
Oh, shit.
Wait.
What the fuck?
Oh, shit.
Now there's two of you?
Alright.
There you go.
We're fine.
I'm trying to hurt your child.
I'm not hurting my child.
He's not right.
He's not real.
My axe goes through him.
So, he's just a figment of my imagination because I'm living through the guilt of my dead wife.
You are not ready for trolls, boy.
Alright.
I know.
I just...
What's this?
I've always admired...
Oh.
Boys typically hunt in packs and will try to surround their prey.
Father would try to keep them in front of him and let me help draw their attention.
Damn!
What's this?
Oh.
Are you drawing?
What the fuck is that?
No boy of mine is going to fucking draw.
We are hunters, boy.
Alright.
Oh, hey.
A dead man.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
Let's ask more Lu.
He just didn't end up.
Oh.
My boy is not going to be a hunter.
He is...
Oh, wait.
No.
My boy is not going to be an artist.
He is a hunter.
Alright.
Let's head off.
Let's go.
Let's pull this thing.
Alright.
Come on, boy.
Go into the little gate that's apparently U-sized.
Very convenient.
Oh.
What's that?
There you go.
And then we're going to go here.
Alright.
Let's go.
Nice.
We did it.
We're so smart.
Man.
This is why I'm the god of war.
I think he's this way.
Yeah.
But there's Lu.
Look.
We need Lu.
So I can be the strongest.
Alright.
Let's see.
Up we go.
Let's go.
Oh my god.
I don't like it when he, like, fucking straddles me like that.
Where did he come from?
Where the fuck did he come from, too?
Wait.
I want to see how he...
Okay.
I don't know.
It's like a little fucking goblin.
You know?
Like those...
It's like those, like, Dragon Ball Z green guys.
That's why I'm uncomfortable.
It reminds...
Okay.
So that does fire.
It reminds me of those, like, Dragon Ball Z goblin guys.
That, like...
That fucking explodes when you hug them like that.
Wait.
Can I cut the rock?
I can't cut the rock?
Wait.
But can I cut this?
No.
Okay.
Yeah.
The Cyberman.
He's your little goblin.
It reminds me of that.
That makes me uncomfortable.
It feels like he's gonna fucking explode.
Okay.
Is there anything here?
No.
What's over here?
Is this loot?
Loot.
What is this?
Boy.
I can't read.
Wait.
I actually can't read.
My guy is just like me.
For real.
What's happening there at the end?
They eat the sun and moon?
And then everybody fights?
Oh.
Okay.
So.
Find all the shrines.
There's a giant lift behind the shrines that tell stories from their history.
I love these stories.
My mom told them.
Let's see how many we can find.
I fucking knew it.
I can't read.
That's why I keep him around.
His mother taught him how to read so I don't have to read.
So.
Wolf giants.
Skull chases the sun and hate the moon.
What happens when they catch their prey?
Looks like a massive fish.
Could it be?
I fucking knew it.
That's why I kept him.
So I can have the reader.
So he can read all the lore for me.
What is he doing?
Invading Nordic lands.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, okay.
Why is it blue and not yellow?
I can't read in blue.
Alright, nice.
Then, open.
Alright.
Let's see.
Get some money.
And some loot.
Sound guy, does it sound better now?
Boy, translate this, boy.
Wait, have I been here?
Where did I come from?
Where did I go?
Cotton Eye Joe.
Oh no, this is where he gripped me.
And I was like, ooh.
Alright.
Oh, shit.
Whoops.
Well, we gotta do this again.
I went the wrong way.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Nice.
We did it.
Oh, I can...
Alright, give me a sec.
Alright.
One last adjustment, guys.
And then it'll be perfect.
But also, I need to, like, bring up my...
I need to bring up, like...
The Super Chats.
Because I couldn't see them earlier.
I'm sorry.
No, but thank you again for the...
I don't even remember if I read this.
But no, but thank you again for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Needs some yellow paint.
It does.
Why is it blue?
For...
50 years!
It's been yellow!
And they decided to make it blue?
Wait, did he, like, illegally cross the border to get to Nordic lands?
He's simply a target.
Clear your mind.
What if I shoot him in the butt?
Steady your aim and...
Feet solid.
Steady yourself.
Exhale and release.
That's not the point!
I can't believe it!
The gill...
There's no choice.
This is the illusion of choice.
I can't believe it!
It's...
I was robbed.
This was a cutscene that's already been made.
Kill him.
Do it.
Huh?
Stab him in the head.
Do it.
Your mother would be so proud.
Don't look at him.
Stop looking!
The longer you look, the more you'll feel!
Bro, why is he doing it so... Bro, why do it so slow?
That's fucked!
That's fucked, man.
He could've been like...
He's like, alright, you're gonna watch the light drain from his eyes as we slowly plunge it in.
That's the only way to go.
You did it, boy.
You killed your first deer.
Congratulations!
Wow!
Oh my god!
Where did he come from?
That's my deer!
Oh shit!
Where's his weak spot?
Press 12 to command or shoot arrows.
Hold 2 to target.
Hold 2 and square and press to target.
Enemies will be distracted from attacking.
Oh, that's cool.
Number of arrows can shoot is indicated in the lower right.
One shot, arrows take time to recharge.
Alright, is he shooting his arrows?
Do it now!
Get... It's fine!
That's fine!
Do it now!
Am I doing any damage?
I don't know!
Wow!
Do it now!
Shoot him!
Oh my god.
I know!
I'm trying to aim for it!
I am trying!
I'm not a controller player!
I am... Please!
I am absolutely trying to shoot it over there!
I don't know if you can tell, but I am!
Please!
I am absolutely trying my best!
Oh my god!
Oh shit!
Wow!
Shoot him!
I am commanding him!
Oh my god!
Please!
I'm not good at aiming on the fucking controller!
I... I reflexively go for head!
It's like a curse!
It's a curse!
Why is your weak point on your arm?!
Is that where your brain is located?!
Why?!
Oh god.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, this is fine.
This is fine.
Slow and steady wins the race!
Slow and steady...
wins the race!
I am fighting!
I will fight...
with just my...
axe of war!
And that's how you do it.
That's how you do it.
Get in here!
That's right!
Go bash your brains out!
No!
Aim...
This is aim.
That's fucking right.
What the fuck?!
Damn!
The god of cheese wins again!
They give us super chat cats!
They can take...
Oh!
Oh, he has issues already!
We did it?!
Boy, what did you do?
weren't.
Are
you serious?
I found the deer.
I proved myself!
Ready!
We are going home...
Boy, you didn't even shoot at the yellow!
I have insisted for a long time!
to be fair, I'm not very great teacher!
I've been holding on...
Good, I appreciate that!
I am NOT ready!
JOGO JP on mute!
Sorry, my controller failed.
SHA ان!
Haha!
So am I ready!
Grab the Diablos!
I had to blow my nose and I dropped my controller.
Alright.
Sorry.
Sorry, boy.
Alright, you're not ready.
Damn!
You've lost your speaking privileges, boy.
Jeez.
Holy shit.
Imagine telling your child that.
You're not allowed to speak again.
Alright.
Mother always used to tell me stories about him to try and scare me if I wandered off too far.
I think she'd be proud of me, but father thinks because I got a little angry that I'm not ready.
Whatever.
I just helped him kill a troll.
I know I'm ready.
Mother told me a lot of stories about trolls.
The one's name translates to death merchant.
With a name like that, I think it's safe to assume he was pretty evil.
Damn.
That my boys got anger issues.
That's when I know he's definitely mine.
Now I know this boy is mine.
Just like your old man.
Alright.
Here we go.
Let's see.
Blitz, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Who's he trying to shoot at?
Kill him.
Okay.
An enemy's stun bar is located below their health bar.
Attacking an enemy in quick succession inflicts stun damage, causing the bar to fill.
You can grab it.
Arrows and barehanded attack inflicts extra stun.
You can switch to by throwing an axe or sheathing the axe.
Sheathing the axe?
Why would I need to ever sheathe the axe?
Alright.
Where the fuck did my axe go?
Was it still in his fucking body?
Like...
What?
I didn't even realize it was still in his body.
Whoa!
They can dodge?
I dodged this.
Okay.
Can my boy die?
Alright.
Nice.
Headshot.
Easy.
Boy, what the fuck?
That's a bush.
That's a rock!
You shot a rock!
See, this is why you're not ready.
You literally shot a rock.
Dodge this.
Alright.
Let's see.
Are there any loot in the boxes or are they just here to troll you?
Oops.
I meant to do that?
Wait, what?
What?
Am I supposed to...
Hold journal.
Find and enter all chambers when able.
There are six, seven locked doors.
How do I unlock it?
Open sesame.
Still can't get the doors open, huh?
Oh.
Quiet.
I have to touch it for later?
I have to come back here?
Quiet.
Damn.
Oh.
Is there... Oh, there is loot!
Wait!
I could've got extra loot this entire time?
Oh.
Oh shit.
Okay.
I missed out on a lot of loot.
I didn't know!
Oh!
Oh my god!
I missed out on all the loot!
I can't believe it!
Oh, that was health?
Okay.
That doesn't matter then.
Alright.
Shoot him.
Now I'm gonna do this.
That's alright.
Nice.
Boy, shoot him too!
Boy!
Shoot him!
Let your anger out!
Build it all up inside!
Wait, what?
Whoa!
You made me dodge.
I don't like that.
I didn't play this game to fucking dodge.
What is it?
He's gonna... What?
He... What?
Okay.
What?
Oh.
That's right.
I will use my fist.
Oh, you think...
You think I don't have legs?
That's right!
I will kick you!
That...
No way!
You think the axe is all I can do?
No!
That's fucking right!
Get outta here!
I use an axe cause I'm lazy!
How dare you make me put an effort!
Take him to the wall!
Let's see.
Wolf giants, skull... Oh, wait.
What?
That's not what I wanted to look at.
Alright.
Let's see.
Is there anything here that I missed out on?
We finally got a proper...
What is that supposed to mean?
All that I'm saying is the axe is 100% faster.
It's cause I'm moving, okay?
It's a lot harder when you're moving.
I just need to know two moves.
Alright.
The marked tree returned to the house.
But why would a fire troll
think that attack was a good idea?
I don't know.
Boy, I said quiet.
Boy.
I said quiet.
Do you not know what quiet means?
Alright.
Back home we go!
Yeah!
Is this not home?
Yeah, this is home cause this is where we burned our wife.
Look!
Some of the parts aren't fully burned yet.
So let me chop it.
I knew I should have chopped it up.
Are those trees or that?
Those are the parts of my dead wife.
I can't tell.
I can't tell if that's bark or not.
Okay.
Let's go inside.
Go inside.
It's time to sleep.
I'm not disrespecting her, see?
I'm paying tribute right now!
After I just dis... before I disrespected her.
Damn, I'm depressed.
Now I have two dead wives.
Oh.
I clearly like this one more than the other one.
Cause I don't think I have a momentum of her.
I mean I'm getting better.
I only have one... I didn't have two dead children this time.
So I'm improving.
My record's getting better.
Third time's a charm like they say.
She's on my skin?
Am I worrying my dead first wife?
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Holy shit!
What the fuck is wrong with him?
You lost control.
That thing was trying to kill us.
It's not like you don't get anger in a fight.
Anger can be a weapon.
If you control it.
Use it.
You clearly cannot.
I haven't been sick in a long time.
I'm better now.
Fine.
Come on then.
He want me to hit you.
I want you to try.
Let's smack him.
Damn!
Too slow.
Cut it out!
Weak.
Again.
Again!
Stop it!
That's right.
You're weak.
How dare you not have the reflexes of a god.
You
can get lost in it.
The battle ahead is difficult.
And you, Atreus, are clearly not ready.
Damn.
What was that?
Quiet.
That's fucked.
Dad of the year.
Who's that?
There's no use hiding anymore.
I know who you are.
Who doxxed him?
What's going on?
Do you know him?
More importantly.
Suddenly I know what you are.
Boy.
Beneath the floor.
Now.
But you told me never to go down there.
Who is that?
I do not know.
What's he talking about?
Get in.
Just tell me what I want to know.
No need for this to get bloody.
I heard there's a Greek god here.
In Nordic town.
Was he?
I thought you'd be bigger.
You're definitely the one.
Long way from home, aren't you?
What do you want?
Oh, you already know.
Oh my god.
He is trying to kick me out.
He knows I got here illegally.
You don't have it.
You should move on.
And here I thought you're kind.
You're supposed to be so annoying.
Conner McGregor.
Better than this.
So much smarter.
Oh my god.
He's angry at a Greek god.
As in Nordic country.
Like a coward.
The Norse border control.
That's fucked.
You're far from Greek, boy.
Whoa.
Leave.
Home.
This ain't your home, boy.
You're going to have to kill me for that to happen.
Oh.
Finally.
You would not listen.
No, no, no.
Where the fuck are you?
Which Greek god are you?
Or not Norse god are you?
My turn.
Oh.
Where did he go?
Where's the mussel?
Oh, where's your gun, though?
Yeah.
That's right.
Oh, shit.
Wait.
Oh, that's right.
I knew it.
I knew I could still do this.
No.
That's right!
Get close to me!
That's fucking right!
What you gonna do?
Walk slowly towards me?
That's right!
You can't get close to me to do anything!
Get further away!
Oh, no.
No!
Wait, that's not supposed to...
Whoa!
Oh, get... Fuck, bro!
That's right!
Get... Oh, shit!
Okay.
He's... He's very quick, guys.
You know what?
I'm tired of this.
How dare you.
Whoa, fuck!
Is he Quick Time Inventing me?
Oh, no.
It's part of the cutscene.
There's no way this isn't part of the cutscene.
Get this dude.
Why did he have to put...
Oh, does he know?
Does he know?
R1.
What?
R1?
Counter this, bitch!
That's fucking right!
That's right.
R1!
That's fucking right!
I know how to R1!
Get out of here!
Slow and old.
You should never have come to Midgard.
Wait, what the fuck?
He can regenerate?
Can't you try again?
That's not fair!
You talk too much.
Oh, shit.
He's so fast.
He maxed out on Agility.
And Strength?
Maybe whoever it is you've got stashed in that house will.
L.
R.
Spartan Rage?
Use the anger!
Use the anger, Kratos!
R1 him!
Jesus Christ.
Who is this?
Who are you afraid of?
Fine!
Jeez!
Holy fuck!
Now that I have the...
What the fuck?
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Okay, yep.
I'm angry.
Oh, I am so fucking angry.
Where are you?
I'm fucking mad!
I'm so mad!
Anger issues!
I don't need anger therapy!
If I let my problems out onto other guys, I'm gonna let them go!
Oh, shit!
No, wait, wait, wait, wait.
That's not what I wanted.
There you go.
Alright.
Oh, shit!
No!
I wanted to cheese you!
How dare you!
How fucking dare you!
I will...
Yeah, that's fucking right.
That's right.
That's fucking right.
I will cheese you if it's the last thing I do.
Get...
Get cheese!
That's fucking right.
Where's your strength now?
I am the god of cheese.
I shall crush you with a rock now.
The fuck?
How did I get the rock in the back?
Nice.
I made a pancake.
I made a little pancake.
And now I go home.
I did my job, boy.
Alright.
What a good day.
But how do I go home?
Where do I go?
Wait, where do I go?
How can I be lost already?
This is a very small area.
Oh, there it is.
There's the tiny pathway.
Yeah!
Whoa!
Wait, he's alive?
Jesus Christ.
What the fuck?
Did you regenerate again?
Is there a phase three?
Yeah, when Odin sent me here.
I just needed answers, but you, you had to act all proud.
Throw whatever you have at me.
I'll keep coming.
That old body will give out.
But before I end this, I want you to know one thing.
I can't feel any of What?
What?
Oh!
He's a sociopath!
Oh, shit.
I gotta cry.
You've seen it with your own eyes.
Oh, he meant pain.
Nothing can.
This fight is pointless.
Your struggle is pointless.
You didn't have to be this way.
Not like that!
Oh, shit!
What is he?
You can't win!
I feel nothing!
He's not a sociopath.
He's European.
You're the Super Chat Cast.
Thank you, thank you.
You've given me what I wanted.
It wouldn't have ended this way.
But no!
He's just Scandinavian.
They don't see the sun.
It's like this.
Wait, I do have a Phase 3!
That's fucked!
Oh, shit!
Oh, my god.
Get out of here!
Get out!
Wow!
Okay, I know how to do that then.
God damn!
I'm gonna die!
What the fuck?
He stunned me.
Get out!
Whoa, shit!
That's fucking right!
Get out of here!
Bad!
Bad boy!
Okay.
I need to dodge here.
Bro, like, that's not a good thing!
Bro!
Oh, shit!
Every time he...
Okay, I got an idea.
I got an idea.
Pew!
Oh!
Boom!
Bad!
I don't know if you know this, but that's not working!
Come on!
Get over here!
You know what?
Fuck yeah, I'll make the first move.
Oh, shit!
You have literally three moves, man!
You're pissing me off!
Oh!
Nice!
Pew!
Oh!
Oh, shit!
Back up!
Come on!
Get over here!
Oh, damn!
Do I need to time that?
Get over here!
Come on!
Back off!
Get over here!
I have to use my regular axe throwing!
Wait, where did you go?
Here we go.
Oh, I can counter it.
Okay.
Oh, there we go!
Oh, I see!
I just need to time it correctly.
Oh!
Wow!
He can do that?
That's fucking right.
Come on!
Dodge.
Alright, now that I know I can time that, it's over for him.
It's fucking over.
Bro, I know you feel nothing!
That's an issue that you have to tell your therapist, not me!
I'm just here to kick your ass!
Alright.
He's too fast.
He upped his agility so I can't throw my axe on him anymore.
Break his neck!
Do it!
Yeah, do it!
Regenerate this!
Oh, shit.
That's right.
Can't regenerate if you can't breathe!
UFC moment!
Tap out!
Tap out, fool!
Yeah!
Regenerate your fucking neck, bitch!
You didn't tap out.
Could've tapped out!
And he is out.
I'll never know who he was.
It was good sparring partner dough.
That was male therapy!
Who was he?
Yeah, which Greek god was he?
Alright.
Don't worry.
That's not fair.
Why can't I regenerate just like him?
I'm Greek.
Anyway.
Oh, is that the one I banged?
That's our dead wife.
Oh, wait!
I did!
I regenerate so hard that there's less blood on me now.
That's how regeneration works.
How did I have less blood in three seconds?
And the blood is gone!
And the blood is now gone.
Damn.
I absorbed it into my body.
It just works.
I just absorbed it back in.
That's how my regeneration works.
Knock knock.
But we cannot stay here.
Boy, we have to leave, boy.
They found out where we live.
We don't actually have to passports to live here.
A lot of skin care.
That's right, boy.
I've killed other gods before that they made three games of it.
Do you think since the god is from Scandinavia that it'll be different?
Yay!
Defend your home!
I got an achievement!
I won a UFC match against Conor McGregor.
That's what happened.
New entry.
A strange man covered in tattoos came to the house and I don't have to pay Cable for it!
That's great!
An attacked father.
It must have been some fight.
Everything's broken.
Father said I wasn't ready earlier, but something about killing this stranger changed his mind, I guess.
Who was he?
What did he want with us?
We're nobodies.
Okay.
Wings, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I had you on while I was cooking and it was just loud enough to hear, but not loud enough to hear what you were saying.
Roommates asked what gym bro are you watching?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That's right, boy.
And you too will kill your next god as well.
Yay!
You could've died.
Don't worry, son.
I'll make sure you die.
That's so fucked.
Like, why?
Our boy was like, don't leave me alone.
I was like, fine!
I don't wanna get in the fight!
That's what.
Close your heart to the suffering.
Holy shit!
I mean, okay.
Alright, dad.
Get rid of all feelings when you kill.
So you can kill more.
Oh, there's money.
Money!
He's dead, so he doesn't need the money anymore.
Keep that shit up.
Oh, my axe was never with me.
I summoned it all the way from where I killed Conor McGregor.
There you have it.
For those who don't know who Conor McGregor is, he is a very famous boxing person.
Um...
Let's see...
What do I have to do from that?
Or UFC person.
Sorry, things with fists all blur together for me.
Uh...
I just see all of them as fists.
They do something with their fists so they all blur in.
Good idea!
Alright.
Here we go.
Wait, what did I do?
Okay.
The Fisters.
He's just a famous Fister.
What did I do?
Command to drop...
Oh, this.
Okay.
Here we go.
Alright.
Let's go.
Yay!
Kickboxing just doesn't exist.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This is a really good video.
I really, really appreciate it.
And please, I'm really very glad that you saw the video.
I personally like the content of this video.
I really, really appreciate it.
Make sure you have a great day and
Bye!
Alright, was that it?
Did I just do that for loot?
Okay, I need to do this.
Alright.
Because I care, unlike those Norse gods.
Alright, nice.
Where am I supposed to go?
The fuck?
Was there something over there originally?
Oh, I was supposed to go to my child.
Sorry, I got distracted by loot as always.
I got distracted by loot.
The loot goblin ran strong in me.
Alright, look up where?
Alright, let's grab this.
Alright, I'll just go to the other side.
Up we go.
I don't know what to use this loot for yet.
What?
Jump.
What am I supposed to do?
Jump!
Alright, yeah, the quick time event didn't show up.
Or not quick time, the button prompt didn't show up there.
That's weird.
What?
We don't own anything.
How are they supposed to rob us?
Oh wait, is that the faster way to do it?
What?
Oh, there was a shortcut there.
I didn't even notice.
Yeah, boy, we're broke as fuck.
We don't own anything.
Rob us of what?
Alright, nice.
We have another shortcut here.
Let's see.
I gotta make sure I got everything.
Alright.
Let's go up.
Darkblade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
TLDR, Aeris made Kratos rage and see his wife and kids as enemies so he killed them.
Their ashes went into Kratos' skin.
Oh, they're literally on me!
So my dead wife and chi- I'm like feeding my dead wife and child of god blood.
So they'll be satisfied.
They're always hungry.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Did you cut those down?
I gotta feed my dead wife and child.
They're hungry.
Always so hungry.
That's why the blood disappeared so fast.
Alright.
Let's see.
Alright, let's go.
Let's go, child.
Gotta beat up some rocks real- Beat up some boxes real fast.
Uh... this way.
Alright, boy!
Come on!
You can jump, boy!
Do what daddy did!
Nice.
Alright.
Am I skinny enough for this?
Damn.
It just fit my chest.
I do not know.
Before winter falls?
Okay, okay.
Alright, boy!
They don't see us.
Should I fire?
Yes.
Wait for my mark.
That's my mark.
We're all around here!
Yes, we always kill.
Yes!
You got this, boy!
You got this!
You're ready!
It's not like you'll die or anything.
You can't die.
You're just a figment of my imagination.
Of my guilt of letting my wife die.
I'm just...
There you go.
Boy, attack!
Keep attacking, boy!
Never...
Boy!
This is why you're not ready!
I literally saw you miss!
Wait, what?
Oh, shit!
They get fired back?
Okay, that is like...
So slow, though.
Alright, boy.
Boy, you could have done that a little faster.
Threat indicators point towards off-screen.
Gold signifies nearby enemies.
Red signifies purple.
Indicates an incoming projectile.
Wait, they're all dead, though.
Ooh!
Okay, I don't think I need that at all.
Wait, is there more?
Oh, shit!
Goodbye!
There was more.
Oh, shit!
Okay!
Alright.
Gotta get you out of the way.
Sorry.
I need you further away so I can do this.
Come on!
Keep shooting!
Just keep shooting!
It's alright!
You can die!
You're nearly invincible!
Take every... hit!
Oh, shit!
Not me!
Guys!
Go!
Go, boy!
You got this!
I believe in you!
Just keep shooting!
Just... just keep shooting!
Oh, shit!
That's fine.
I'll be okay.
Okay.
Alright.
This guy.
I know he can't hit.
There we go.
Oh, my God!
How are you still alive?
You're so weak!
That's fine!
Boy, please!
Alright.
Last guy.
Where are you?
You're so lucky there's a tree there.
You're so lucky.
There we go.
Nice!
That was easy.
And we got X-Men!
We got XP from that!
Try light throws.
It's faster.
Whoever is not my focus should be yours.
But only when safe to do so.
Yeah, but it's not not as strong though.
But it's not as strong.
What's this?
Boy, read!
Read, boy!
What does it say?
Yetnar.
Giants.
You can read the writing.
Some.
Just the language is mother now.
But they're all...
Alright.
Would have connected so sometimes I can feel my way through stuff I shouldn't know.
You know?
What's this?
Okay, so...
I need to make sure that I'm not missing anything here.
I want to make sure that I got everything.
Oh, loot!
Nice.
I don't know when I'll ever use this loot yet.
But I love loot.
I love to loot.
Oh, wait.
There's jars.
There has to be stuff in jars, right?
Yeah, I knew it.
I knew there's gold in here.
Fae is...
Fae is Nordic, right?
I always like...
I read so much about Greek...
Not Greek, but like gods and goddesses in general that I sometimes get confused which is which.
Because they all blur together for me.
Yeah.
Oh, so I banged a Nordic goddess!
What the fuck are you?
Wait, can you be hit?
Oh, wait!
That's the...
The yo...
Whatever?
The...
What Loki is?
Yoner?
What?
I can...
Yoren?
I don't know how to pronounce it.
They're the frost giants!
That's the frost giants.
Yeah!
The yo something!
Oh, they're ice giants!
They're zombies, but they're blue!
How dare they?
But they're blue though!
An extremely quick burst of energy that interrupts and knocks back all nearby enemies?
Wait, how do I do that?
You have acquired a Hell's Touch Light runic.
Runic gems allows you to customize your weapons to enable light and heavy runic attack.
Look down to access the...
Oh.
Oh!
Wait, no.
I don't want it to be light.
XP to upgrade.
Improves their attributes.
Press X to equip it.
Okay.
Okay, I don't want this to be...
Wait, how do I remove it?
Press L1 to R1.
Not enough XP.
Uh...
Finalize!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Another game similar to God of War is a serious rap.
Synopsis for both is literally just Florida man too angry to die.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Okay, I need to remember...
I need to remember this.
Whoa!
Do I recharge it?
All right.
Let's see.
All right, up we go.
Move.
Thanks.
There's the mountain!
Let's go!
Not yet!
What am I waiting for?
It's five!
Let me jump on...
You fucking idiot!
You're so...
You're so stupid.
Survival of the fittest boy.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Survival of the fittest.
All right.
Don't worry.
I'm coming over.
Hang on!
I'm coming!
Stay calm!
Almost there!
You need to learn.
Never jump on the middle of the bridge to test it out!
That wasn't so bad.
Slow.
Down.
Yeah.
Slow down.
Your haste will cost us.
Sorry.
Ugh.
More draugr.
But these aren't moving.
Are they dead?
I mean...
More dead?
Yeah.
Why aren't they moving?
Don't touch the...
Boy!
By color and number near their health bar.
The color and health range from green to purple depending on how powerful they are compared to Kratos.
That's right, boy.
That's right.
That's fucking right, boy.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
I like the faster one better, actually.
You're right.
Whoever said try to do faster?
I should...
You know what?
This is easier.
This is much...
Oh!
But the fast...
The heavy one does...
Alright.
The fast one, he'd be like, get away!
Get away!
Get away.
Ha!
Okay.
Then I'll use this.
Get away!
That's...
That's stupid.
Get away!
Get away from here!
Don't touchy!
No touchy!
No touchy.
Ha!
No touch.
Oh shit.
Okay, maybe I gotta get rid of you first.
No touch.
Oh shit.
Get away.
Bad.
Okay, you two up there.
You're the weaker ones.
So I'm going to get rid of you guys first.
There we go.
What are you trying to do?
Huh?
You idiots.
Get away.
There you go.
Nice.
Just gotta make sure.
Alright, I just want to make sure that there's no evil guys here.
Alright.
That was easy.
Alright, no touchy.
Look at what?
Yeah?
Read.
Read, boy.
Oh.
Found what used to be...
Found what used to be a marketplace.
Okay.
What?
Where?
Oh.
Cool.
Oh, shit.
You big boy.
It's alright.
Goodbye.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, there's more!
Oh, shit!
Okay.
I did not expect more.
I thought it was one guy.
It's fine.
How is there so many?
What?
Oh, my God!
How am I supposed to abuse my axe when there's so many of you guys?
It's fine.
Whoa.
Please don't make me do this.
Because I win.
Okay.
I guess I will melee you all.
Oh.
Okay.
Alright.
You made me angry.
You made me angry now.
I will fight you with my gun.
With my gunaxe.
That's fucking right.
There you go.
I am playing the video game.
You die by gunaxe.
Nice.
I had to let go of my limiters for a second there.
Wait.
I want the money.
No!
Oh, wait.
No.
That's it.
Those are just heals.
Okay.
Never mind.
Those are just heals.
Let's see.
I want to make sure I got everything.
Alright.
Up I go.
Oh.
There's somebody here.
Did you hear that?
Yeah.
What is it?
Who's there?
We will see.
Stay close.
What is there?
Hello?
Ma'am?
Old lady?
Where is that from?
I want to make sure I get rid of these guys first.
There you go.
Because I don't trust it.
That's how you grow up to be a man, boy.
We don't have any self-preservation here.
We go straight in.
Oh!
Okay.
Alright, boy.
Maybe we should have listened to our boy.
Alright.
That's fine.
It's fine.
There we go!
See?
We're so fine!
Easy.
Alright.
Okay.
They're called revenants.
Alright.
Nice.
We did it.
We're the kill leader.
Alright.
Mother once told me that some witches trade little bits of their soul here to become more powerful in magic.
Eventually, they'll lose every part of their...
Oh, my God.
Look at their backs.
That's a gamer posture right there.
They can disappear in an instant and these particular revenants are able to spread poison through touch and breath.
Oh, nice.
Alright.
They have a gamer back.
That's for sure.
It's a gamer.
Yeah.
Is that like...
Oh, that guy down.
Poor man.
Oh, I guess not.
Oh!
Nice.
Look at that.
We're so...
We're so nice.
Wait.
Can I...
What is that?
There's like something over here.
There's like a grave over there for me to desecrate.
I love desecrating graves.
Let's go!
How the fuck?
How did he jump on my back like that?
What the fuck, boy?
That's right.
He went coming alive on my watch.
Alright.
He's a fucking monkey.
Wait.
Can I break this?
No.
I see wood.
I want to break.
That's how it goes.
Okay.
I got to make sure these guys don't come alive.
I just don't...
Okay.
There's fall off.
Like, what?
Alright.
Okay.
Are you...
How does there fall off?
Like, oh my...
I will get you!
Yes.
Bully.
Get out.
Get away.
That's fucking right.
I can't believe I threw the axe.
Holy shit.
I...
Okay.
I didn't even melee him.
I just fucking threw it.
I...
Okay.
Nice.
Alright.
Oh...
I fucking knew it.
I knew it!
Alright.
That's the only thing you can do.
Yeah.
Oh god.
Bro, that guy's aim is just as worse as yours.
All right, come on.
Get over here.
You can't dodge this forever!
That's fucking right!
Shoot him in the head!
Oh my god, he blocked me!
Bro!
I'm trying to get this other guy!
Okay, now I can use the heavy.
All right, get out of here.
Get out.
You're level one.
You're a little baby.
What are you doing in here?
Oh, wait, you're a little baby.
All right, last guy.
Nice.
That's right, you can't get close to us.
That's right!
Easy.
All right, there should be some loot here.
I love loot.
Wait, I can charge it?
No, I can't.
You lied.
I thought I could charge it.
You guys made me so excited.
I could have abused this even more.
Unlimited.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
Wait, I can?
How?
Am I charging it?
Oh, it's an upgrade.
Okay, you guys know why I'm gonna upgrade first.
Yes.
That's gonna be the...
Read, boy!
Read, I'm illiterate!
I learned to fight not to read.
That's why I banged your mother.
She was my reader.
And now you're gonna be my new reader.
All right, let's see.
I needed a guide.
All right, boy, it's time to read again.
Another.
Read.
He says his name is...
Hrungnir.
Mother told me about him.
A giant warrior.
Did my fists do the talking?
Odin's there?
Thor?
Where's the World Serpent again?
The ground serpent.
What about Loki?
Is Loki hot in this version too?
See?
But look.
Hrungnir's body squished him.
Idiot.
Oh, we found more of the shrines.
Hrungnir.
All right.
Let's go.
I wonder if Loki is hot in this one too.
There's always a hot Loki.
He's a god of mischief for a reason.
All right.
Let's see.
Where do I go?
Oh, here.
I can't believe I already got lost.
Yeah.
Fire.
Let there be fire.
Okay.
Alright.
Phew!
Okay, one... where's the second one?
Are they all here?
Are they all in the same room or are they further away?
Let's see...
Where are the other ones?
Where would the other ones be?
Where's the other...
Oh, it's the same room?
Uh... they're usually close by.
Okay.
Oh, I found... is that one of them?
Is that one?
Okay, there's falloff, so...
Holy shit!
Okay, that's the last one.
Alright, nice.
Nice.
Gun of war.
Nice, I got another.
I need one more apple.
Gamer of the year.
Jump.
Alright.
Oh, chest!
Loot time!
Loot.
I wonder if I go... can I go this way?
No.
Can I jump this way?
But there's, like, something over there.
I don't know if, like, I'll be heading there soon.
So... let's see.
I will be, eventually.
I have to get up there soon, so...
Oh, no.
Wait, can I... are these the guys I can... no.
God damn it.
God, get over here.
Okay.
Oh!
Oh, shit.
Punch.
Alright, get over here!
Get over here!
That's right!
How dare you be immune to my axe!
I think you got him.
Nice.
Oh, shit.
Alright, time.
Alright, use my boy's arrows on you.
That's right.
Oh!
There's more than one!
It's alright, boy!
Distract him!
Distra... Oh, shit!
That hits me?
That's right, boy!
Just take as much damage as you can!
Oh, shit.
It's okay!
Take as much damage!
You have infinite HP!
It'll be fine!
You're so healthy!
Jesus, Chris.
I need to do the heavy attack on you.
Alright.
Aggro him!
Aggro him, boy!
So I can abuse my axe!
Alright.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
No!
He's so fucking...
Spaz!
Alright.
We're gonna make sure we can...
Jesus, they're all range!
They're all range!
Bro, what the fuck?
Why did you not dodge my son's arrows?
You dodged my axe, but not my son's arrows?
That's fucked!
Okay.
There we go.
Nice.
You know what?
No, fuck you.
Fuck you!
Nice.
Alright.
Oh, shit.
I don't think I needed that.
Arrow is faster.
What is that thing?
Okay.
If these things do manage to freeze us, we should stay on the defensive until it passes.
Alright.
Nice.
Never get close to me again, bitch.
Follow me.
Alright.
Hope she learns her lesson.
Uh...
Never time.
Alright, boy.
Get on the other side.
Get on the other side for dead!
Is there like...
Where's the thing I'm supposed to... Is it here?
What?
It's like here, but like how do I...
Oh.
Oh!
God, I'm so... Okay.
Stop.
Okay.
Alright.
Stop.
There we go.
I didn't see that.
That's cool.
I like that.
Look at that.
See?
I can use my brain sometimes.
Guys?
Guys!
I told you guys!
There's still some connectivity going down there.
The synapses are still firing.
They're still firing!
Alright.
Let's see if I can get my axe back.
Open the chest.
What does it reveal?
Alright.
Nice.
Oh, I got some steel.
I guess those are for my axe upgrades.
What's that?
Oh, more coins.
Am I slowly walking?
All these dead.
Oh.
You think it's safe in there?
You think it's safer out here?
It's always safe.
It'll be safe when I kill everybody.
Get over there, boy.
What's that smell?
It's called bodies.
That's why we burned up your mother.
Are they Hellwalkers?
Wait.
Peep humans?
Someone start the fires!
Sigmund, you're nice.
So many days without meat.
Peepa?
Wait.
Us?
Behind me.
Oh, yeah.
What are cannibals?
What the fuck?
That's fucking right.
Oh, you guys are Peepa.
You guys are Peepa.
You guys...
You guys are weak.
Oh, that's cute.
That's cute.
Oh!
Wait.
Who are you?
That's not Peepa.
That's dead fuck guys.
Who are you?
Where the fuck are you?
Bro, you're behind a fucking...
Wow!
Oh, shit!
You sick shaked him.
You got your first human kill.
How do you feel, boy?
How do you feel?
You feel good?
You feel good, boy?
Don't worry.
I'll chop him up for you so you can get up.
I like how you cannot aim at him anymore.
Wait.
Does it work if I go further away?
Boy, how does it feel?
You got your first kill, boy!
Does it feel good?
Oh, I thought...
I was like, wouldn't it be funny if I could just climb?
Climb away.
All right.
I got to make sure I got the loot.
Oh, boy.
I got some money for us.
Nice.
All right.
I'll come back now.
You like living with the consequences of your actions?
Don't worry.
I got you.
Baby's first human kill.
Congratulations.
Don't worry.
Your skin will start absorbing the blood.
The moment I put this man's egg in his mouth.
You're going to have ashes on your body.
They made a sequel, so you're going to be killing a lot more.
Oh, shit!
You're a man now, boy.
Man.
Man-boy.
It's time to close your heart because we're about to kill some more fools.
Oh, wait.
What?
They're regenerating.
I will handle this.
Oh, they're the ghost guys.
They're the guys that I can't...
Wait.
I got to make sure.
No.
Yeah.
I can't do this.
I can't.
That's good.
That's all I need to know.
Oh, shit.
Except for you.
That's all right.
I don't need it.
Just...
Whoa!
No.
You get this.
Okay.
Wait.
Give me a sec.
Oh, shit.
You get this, though.
You get this and then I'll beat the shit out of him.
That's right!
Get over here!
With you.
Get down!
All right.
Loot.
They came back.
Yeah, they regenerated.
Except for that guy.
Oh, cause he was dead then.
Okay, we gotta figure out how to get out of here, man-boy.
Escape the ruins.
I assume it's here.
Oh wait, is that...
I thought it was here.
What's this?
What is this?
Boy.
Manboy, did you not hear me?
Go drop the chain.
You had to learn how to kill sooner or later.
And it's now soon.
Manboy, don't be so depressed!
We killed so many before!
Oh, he's sad.
He's sad, sad.
Alright, come on!
Arteus!
Oh, that's when you know Dad's serious.
He called him by his first name.
Oh, Arteus!
Manboy!
Close your heart!
Yeah!
It was self-defense!
It was reflex!
And we will go home, boy.
What?
To give up this easily.
So close to the start.
Wait, no!
I'm not giving up!
I can do this!
I just have to...
Ah, manipulation.
Good parenting.
Maybe you were just too weak!
Damn, Kratos!
Damn!
That's fucked!
Holy shit!
Maybe you're just a fucking weak boy!
Jesus Christ!
This boy literally just killed his first man!
He's like, alright, we'll turn around!
We'll just turn around!
That's what you want?
Aren't you the product of it?
Look, my father and his father was raised like this.
And I will continue this circle.
Alright, we're path to the mountains.
Oh, there's a chest here.
Don't make me turn this car around, boy!
Okay, there's something down here, so I'm gonna go check it.
Real quick.
Wait, which way am I supposed to go?
Am I supposed to go this way?
What?
Am I supposed to go this way or the other way?
Let's see.
I'm gonna go this way first and then double check.
Okay, my boy is going that way, so definitely not that way.
Wait, no.
No, he actually went the right way?
I'm so confused.
No, this has to be the right way because there's a bridge.
Okay.
I'm gonna go down then.
Yeah, I'm gonna go down.
Because like there's a bridge.
So that means like this is the not the right way.
This is the loot way.
Oh!
Yoink!
Mine now.
Found a mask.
That means XP.
The boy...
Yeah, the boy like walked away so he knows.
How do I get down though?
I wanna get down.
Is that it?
Was that the only loot?
Oh, I guess it was.
Oh no, I've been here!
What's that sound?
Is that a fairy?
Alright, up I go.
Up I go.
Okay.
Hello.
Oh, it's a crow!
Hello there!
Yay!
Oh, it's the owl!
It's the eyes of Odin!
I knew it.
I knew it!
The birds were spies all along from the government!
The government is Odin!
I fucking knew birds were unreal!
I fucking knew it!
I knew it.
Oh, don't slap him!
That's fucked!
Can't get this slow.
I'd cock hump to cross the bridge.
That's so fucked!
There's something in the trees over there.
There's what now?
Father, throw your axe at those trees on the other side of the bridge.
The ones with the white shrubs.
Oh, okay.
Wait.
Am I supposed to just throw it?
Just this once.
Which trees?
Oh!
These trees!
What?
What is that?
Yeah, he looks- he takes it after me.
Um, I don't see color.
That axe you got there.
It was me what made her.
Me and my brother.
Was one of our best.
Oh, it's your axe?
Nobody else go work on her except for us two.
Oh!
You gotta handle her special.
Or she'll wreck beyond fixing.
I can enhance her for you right now if it so pleases you, son of a bitch.
So what say you?
God!
Damn, no slapper!
I do not believe you.
Oh, slap him.
Come, boy.
There's a rune in the shape of a fork under the grip.
No digger be yadimba.
That was our brand, my brother and me, before we split.
I got half of it right here.
See?
Look, you want I should upgrade her or not?
Yes.
Upgrade.
I want to charge my axe.
I expect an improvement.
Where did I get this axe?
Was it from my wife?
So, where's the other half of the brand?
All my dumb brothers got it.
But I got all the talent.
Look!
Where did he...
When did he set up this tent?
So what did you find out?
Okay.
Welcome to the Dwarthen shop.
From here you can upgrade equipment you already own.
Or craft entirely new weapons.
Brock has given you a frozen flame, a rare resource.
Resources found in the world can be used to craft and upgrade your...
Okay.
Dwarthen magic.
True.
Just like my blood absorption magic.
Kratos equipment has power level and stats.
Upgrading the axe levels up to strength, which contributes to Kratos power.
Kratos power level and stats are displayed here.
Okay.
Renekton.
Damage can be increased by increasing runic.
Runic attack cooldowns can be reduced by increasing cooldown.
Each stat has gameplay benefits.
Press L to hide the description.
Power level and stats gain will be displayed on the item card and also reflects the Kratos stat table.
Updating a weapon permanently increases these stats.
Other items must be equipped to influence Kratos' stat.
Resources required...
Upgrade...
Resources required to upgrade are displayed at the bottom of the item card.
Hold to upgrade.
Okay.
Nice.
New skills are now available on the skill tab.
Yay!
The axe is now level 2.
Upgrading your weapon unlocks new skills for purchase.
Visit the skill tab to purchase them.
Okay.
Oh, I can craft armor.
Which armor should I craft?
Oh, you don't need armor.
You don't even take damage.
You don't die.
It's me who needs armor.
Okay.
I have a lot.
All right.
We're going to...
Ooh.
Do I want to cover my fucking body though?
It's just...
Do I need it?
Ooh.
But then like...
Okay.
I want the plus 7 there.
The tunic.
Nice.
Okay.
Do I need...
Strength is good.
Do I need defense?
Nah.
I won't put a shirt on.
I will refuse to put a shirt on.
I refuse.
Okay.
I'm going to get that then.
Talon.
You don't...
We don't need you to upgrade.
All right.
Let's see.
Nice.
Okay.
We're going...
Might last a day.
Okay.
We're going to get that.
And then...
We don't need to upgrade this for now.
Well, I'll talk now, but our friends who were hiding in the trees are back for more.
Go on.
Let these girls free...
Free the nipple.
Yes!
What the fuck are you doing?
Please!
This is exactly why!
This is exactly why I did not... I did not fucking give him armor and upgrades.
Or bow upgrades.
He doesn't even help!
Oh, now you're not gonna help, boy!
That's fucked!
That's actually fucked!
There we go.
Nice, we're fine.
Didn't I equip it?
Alright.
Let's see.
We did not equip it?
I thought I did!
I crafted it!
No, he doesn't need anything.
I did not!
How do I equip?
Okay, armor.
Okay.
Enchantments.
Do I have?
Some artists have enchantments.
Select.
Oh!
I don't.
Defense!
Yeah!
Luck.
Who the fuck needs luck?
What does luck do?
Oh, it increases gains.
No, we don't need that.
Okay, armor.
Okay, we need that.
And then... get that in.
Luck of Ages?
No.
Nope.
Alright.
Doki, you need it.
But like...
But the strength!
But it's minus six in strength though!
Like...
But it's...
But it's minus six in strength!
But what about my gains, chat?
What about my gains?
I need to run.
That's the end of the game!
Okay, wait.
I need to...
Strength.
Cool...
Do I have any?
Nope, I do not.
Do I have anything for this?
Oh!
Oh, it's just like...
different colors.
That doesn't even matter.
Defender of the...
I feel like...
Oh, the Black Shield looks cool.
Buckler and...
Okay, I'm gonna get the black one.
This one looks sick.
Uh, and then the bow.
Whatever, we don't care about you.
Alright, let's see.
Skills.
Okay, skills.
Range combat!
Alright, let's see.
I have enough for... Do I have enough?
I do.
Oh shit, I wanna charge!
Nice.
Charge axe.
Alright, there you go.
That's all the upgrades I need.
Close combat?
The fuck is that?
Oh, can I talk to you?
Damn,
he went corp bro!
50-50 down the middle.
Guess that was the last thing we saw eye to eye on.
Oh my god, his brother went corp bro and he stayed indie.
You wanna hug?
Hit the road!
Sorry.
Damn.
He was like, I ain't no fucking bootlicker.
I'm gonna fuck... That's... Damn!
Can't believe he would do that to him!
Hahaha!
Alright, let's see.
I wanna make sure there's nothing here.
Is there anything here?
Alright, I don't know if this is the right way.
Or like, the...
Uh...
Alright, here you go.
Oh yeah, this is not the right way.
This is the...
Bonus area!
It's called Tough Love.
He went to work at like, uh, Swarovski or some shit.
I don't fucking know that.
That's jewelry.
I don't know any fucking corporate metal makers.
I was thinking of jewelry and I was like, Swarovski.
It was nice meeting you, Brock.
I'll be thinking you have a name for your beast.
How about I name her fucking Gratitude?
Whoa!
Fucking Gratitude, come over here!
Damn!
Alright, let's go.
Alright.
Time to put my ox in.
Nice.
Hey, watch your hinds in there!
Real good!
Wait, how do you know?
You been here before?
How do you know that?
Oh, so I have to go... I have to go back.
Cause like, there's like a little door here.
I missed a bridge loot?
Oh, there you are.
There you are.
No crows.
That's fucking right.
Oh, there's a bridge loot!
You thought you could hide from me?
I knew it.
All birds are spies.
From the government.
They're the mini drones.
Those are the drones you gotta worry about!
Alright, let's see.
We gotta...
Okay, that's fine.
Let's go back.
Alright.
Give me my axe.
Nice.
Alright.
Let's go.
Let's go to where all the dead bodies are.
Cause that's always a good sign.
Get my axe back.
Oooh.
Woah!
Boy, you liar.
You fucking liar.
I trusted you, boy.
I fucking trusted you.
You said we could go there.
I fucking went up there.
This way.
You said we could go!
Of course I fucking ran up!
Of course I trusted him!
I didn't...
I didn't know he meant, like, I gotta wait.
I didn't know that.
Wait.
How do I get that?
There's, like, a whole...
Oh, wait.
Oh.
There's a...
There's a hole here.
Yay.
Oh, I see.
I see.
Okay.
I'm gonna make sure it's maxed out.
Okay, give me a sec.
Give me a sec.
Don't... Okay.
Is our boy okay?
They...
Are they dead?
I did it.
Is our boy okay?
Where's our boy?
Where did he go?
Where did...
Where did our boy go?
Did he die?
Like, is he okay?
Alright, cool.
We did it.
Wait, how do I get over here, though?
How do I get over on that side?
Where did he go?
Oh!
He's alive!
Wait.
Where is he?
I hear him.
I hear him, though.
How do I get on top?
Oh, I think that was, like, the people I crushed.
I'm pretty sure.
Alright.
Where did he come from?
Wait.
How did he get here?
Never been this close to the mountain before.
Looks so big.
I cast Summon Boy!
No, don't show affection, Kratos.
You're not weak.
Don't...
My father never gave me a hug, so you will never get a hug.
Oh, apparently I missed loot.
How do I...
How do I get it?
Like, I don't even know how to get across.
Oh, I jump.
Okay.
I figured it out.
There is...
Oh shit!
Sorry!
I missed the hole.
Alright.
One of it.
Boom.
Guys.
I missed the hole.
Oh, I can do this again!
Oh!
That's neat!
I can do this all over again!
That's fun!
That's so fun!
Well, now that I know...
Oh, because I... wait...
Oh, but there's loot!
Yay!
Okay, we go back.
I want to get the loot!
Wait, can I do that from here too?
Oh, I can!
Oh!
That's neat!
That's what I was supposed to do!
That's what I was supposed to do during that fight!
Oh!
That makes a lot more sense now!
Hey, but it worked!
Guys, it worked!
Better late than never!
That's what they say!
At least I learned now!
Next time I'm here!
It was speedrunning, exactly!
Where is...
If it works, it works!
Yeah!
But where is, like, the other...
That guy particularly... Oh, wait!
Yay!
I did it the Doki way!
I wanted to show you the Doki way first!
And, like, it killed!
It killed all of them!
Guys!
It killed all of them as well!
So fast!
Like, I see it here!
But, like...
How do I get to that side to, like...
Throw my a...
I see... Is that... Is that it?
Like, it is!
Like, but how do I get it...
Get that?
Huh...
Oh, there's that!
Oh, I raised it... Ow!
Can I raise it from here?
Oh!
I can be higher!
Can I get crushed?
No.
Okay, but, like, how high can this go?
How high can this go?
Is there anything here?
I'm learning!
No, there's nothing here.
It was just for that.
My brain is growing.
The synapses are snapping.
The neurons are snapping right now.
Alright, we can open the chest.
We're gonna get a heart!
Finally!
We got the transplant!
We're on the list!
Nice.
Now we have more HP.
Oh, wait, what?
This is different.
Now I can have maximum rage.
Blood meat is a rare drink that makes one's rage run deeper.
Find the nine horns.
But I wanted a heart!
I wanted a heart!
So I can actually feel something.
Guys, that was a joke.
I can feel.
I need to reiterate.
That was a joke.
Alright, let's see.
Is that reading?
No, that's not reading.
Alright.
Oh, there's loot!
Give me.
Found more masks!
Let's see.
What is it?
Oh, it's a shrine.
Let's go up to it.
The room's written along the side.
Read.
What does it say?
As we are, we two, we three.
It's beautiful.
Because I know it can never be.
A riddle.
Maybe there's a clue around here.
Wait, can you repeat it?
I wasn't listening.
Wait.
What did he say?
Is there a way to repeat the riddle?
Guys, what?
What did he...
I wasn't paying attention.
Seems like maybe those rings should be turning.
Oh, okay.
How do we do that?
How do we...
Oh, there, there, there.
Is that it?
Clearly, it's something.
We have to turn this somehow.
How do we turn it?
Is that a button on his chest?
I use my brain.
We're not going to escape before they succeed.
I played like a fool.
There's a lever.
We're okay.
Now...
There's a lever.
Let's just throw it again.
We still can.
There's a lever.
Let's just throw it again.
Let us do it again.
Yeah.
Okay.
Wait, what?
Oh, oops, I fucked it up.
Okay, I figured it out.
I figured it out, guys.
There we go.
And then, we got to do the inside.
I figured it out.
I told you it's snapping.
Oh, wait, it's the other side.
I'm so smart.
Read.
Boy, read.
Family.
That's the answer.
What I alone can never be.
That's a shitty riddle.
Read your life and trace the ruins into the sand.
Really?
Yes.
Write family now.
Something happened.
Oh.
It worked.
I did it.
A cave.
Alright, let me explore.
The boy is gone.
I'm free now.
Oh, there's nothing else to explore.
Okay.
I got to make sure there's no spies.
Alright.
Everything is good.
There's no spies.
Alright.
Nothing is stronger than family.
Spy.
Spy check.
Doki, that's a regular crow.
They're all spies.
They're...
There's no such thing as regular crows.
Let's see.
Alright.
Nice.
Thank you.
Oh, they're doing like rituals and stuff.
Why can't I steal that money?
Why can't I steal money?
What?
How did I lose?
Oh yeah, I ran into a spike.
Okay, that... I was gonna say, how do I...
lost HP?
Okay, that makes sense.
Why my HP is low.
I thought I heard something.
What?
There's something on the other side.
I hear it.
I hear the...
What are they, boy?
Go, boy.
Track that.
Track that boar.
These are bones.
What the fuck?
Oh shit!
Don't worry!
Now!
What?!
Oh no, I have to be closer.
Oh no.
I have to be so much closer.
Oh no!
It's okay.
We're fine.
What the fuck?
What are you doing here?
This is not your fight.
Whoa!
Go!
That's right.
Oh shit!
No!
I should never get close!
Get close!
Oh god.
I am!
I'm ready!
Okay.
Whoa!
That's right.
Get him, boy.
What's in here?
Where is this behind him?
Oh shit.
It's fine, boy.
Just keep shooting.
Distract him.
I'll be here.
I'll be here!
That's okay.
I'll be here.
Okay, that's fine!
Keep being bait!
You're doing a great job!
I'm proud of you!
Did I say that?
I mean, I'm... I didn't say I'm proud of you, I'm...
Oh my god, okay, you get the melee treatment.
Like, hey, you get the melee treatment right here.
You're distracting me.
What the fuck?
Who is it?
Alright, get over here.
Get out here.
Oh shit, that's okay, we're fine.
We're fine!
We're so fine!
Get out!
This is not your fight!
Are you serious?
Don't worry, slow and steady wins the race!
What the fuck?
I heard something behind me.
It's okay, I hit his butt!
Oh shit.
Goodbye.
Oh, that's where I heard it from.
Oh shit!
Okay, that hurt.
Okay, get over here.
Get over here.
You're not supposed to be in this fight!
Boy, keep doing your thing!
You're doing a good job!
We're doing it!
We're so healthy!
You can live forever, boy!
Trust me!
They made a sequel so I know you don't die!
You can't die because they made God of War II, the sequel!
They made Ragnarok!
Wait, can I like... can I do this from here?
Oh shit!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Nice!
Here we go.
Easy.
Fucking easy.
That's right.
We did it.
Wait, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey, little dokey bird.
We may realize this may be a bad time.
But we're here to collect the second brain cell you rented for today.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
They were human reavers, but now they embrace the way of the seer.
They can throw magic spells at the distance.
That's a lot of loot.
Oh, heavy runic attack!
I like that.
Nice!
Unlikes an additional fall attack by pressing R2 after the initial slam.
Oh, that's something I have to do?
In close range.
I guess.
Alright, what else can I unlock?
Rage combat.
Not enough expo...
Oh wait, do I have enough for...
Oh, these are what I purchased.
Uh, now I'm going to invest in the other stuff.
Expert combat.
Acrobats.
Talon bow.
A certain form when Kratos is attacked.
When Arteus is choking an enemy, he can perform a combat move.
A Kratos launches or hits the enemy.
I can throw the shield?
Say no more.
Hold L-hop to swap.
To break an enemy's block.
Where is it?
After performing the Guardian's...
Where is the shield throw?
Guardian countering blast.
Say no more.
Guardian sweep.
Guys, there's no shield.
Oh, it's in the middle?
That's the...
Justice.
The slams.
Okay, no.
There's no...
I got baited.
I got so baited.
Do I make him do anything?
Is it worth it?
Is it worth it to make him do...
Oh, he's going to learn magic later.
Is it worth...
Is it worth it, guys?
Is it good or no?
Scam?
Is it a scam or...
Is it worth it?
It's pretty worth it.
He's broken.
Okay, which one, guys?
Teamwork, acrobatic, or ferocity?
If it's worth it.
Yes, that's...
That's not an...
That's not...
Guys, I'll pick one.
He deserves only one upgrade for now.
Like...
Stun?
Okay.
Yes is not, like, the answer I was looking for.
I gave, like...
I named three.
Did I need to turn it on?
Oh, the light is on.
Oh, my God.
It's like...
So, like...
Like...
I didn't realize the light was on.
Whoops.
Okay, let's see.
It did not look like the light was on just then.
Oh, my God.
I've been playing for three...
I've been playing for three hours.
This does not feel like three hours.
I've been enjoying this game.
Oh, I've been enjoying this game a lot, actually.
Because it did not feel like three hours.
Oh, what's this?
Okay, there's a chain here.
Oh!
Where?
Where is he reading this?
Like,
where is he reading this?
Like, I...
Oh, these runes?
Oh, okay.
I was like, where is he...
I don't see the words.
But I also can't read.
So, I don't know.
Okay.
I have two of it.
Oh, I need to find the third.
Where is the third?
Where is it?
The third should be nearby, but I don't see it.
What?
Behind?
It's behind.
Behind me?
Oh!
I see it, now.
All right.
And then...
Phew!
Yay!
Okay, it's very generous.
It's very generous.
Thank god.
Because I was like, where...
Where is it?
Yay!
Maximum health!
I got the appas!
Whoa!
That's a lot of HP!
That's a lot.
I realized I never use my rage art.
I just... I don't know.
I just never felt like I needed it.
Let's see.
I hear the crows.
I hear the spies.
I hear them near me.
I hear him.
I know you're spying on me.
I know you're spying on me, croaky!
Where are you?
Okay.
That has to be like the rage art.
Uh, meter thing.
I hear him!
He's like... he's like laughing at me!
Oh my god.
He's... he's hiding.
He's hiding somewhere.
There's like a chain here, but I don't know if I can...
get up there yet.
Is there a way to get up there?
Guys?
Oh shit.
Did I smash that?
Oh, there it is.
Alright, boy.
Come over here.
Boy!
Do your job!
Good job, boy.
Alright, apaco.
Can't hide from me, croaky.
I'm gonna fucking kill you.
Alright.
Read.
What's that?
What is that, boy?
What is that?
New lore?
From here are sacrifices.
Mighty Allfather and Delivered Midgard from Hell's Wild Hunt.
Odin, wisest of all.
Whose breath gave life to Ask and Emba.
First among our people.
We beg your protection.
Send forth your noble Valkyries to call the deathless.
Send forth your noble sons Thor and Balder to shield us.
Send forth dragons to consume the frigid horde.
Save our souls that we may serve you evermore.
Alright.
Cool.
Is that it?
Wait, you see the crow?
That means he's up here.
Where are you?
Where is he?
Did you already got one guide?
I got one guide.
I don't see no crow.
Oh, you bitch.
You thought I didn't see you?
That's right.
Oh my.
That was so...
Oh, that's cheeky.
I knew I could...
I heard...
I could hear him.
I knew I heard him.
I fucking knew it.
I knew I wasn't crazy.
What the fuck?
I know you can break these.
I was like, why can't I break it?
That's right.
You can't hide from me.
Oh, that's where the animal is?
Okay.
That means we don't go there.
So we go this way.
Wait, did I come from here?
Where did I come from?
Where did I go?
I'm so lost.
Did I come from here?
Is this where I came from?
Yeah.
This is where I came from.
So I saw that.
So where does that go?
Cause the board is to the right.
No, this is...
Okay.
No, not this.
I wish mom were here.
Okay.
Look, look, we all do, but you did not have to bring her up.
It's loot.
All right.
Nice.
It's loot.
Okay.
It's gold.
Nice.
Boy, she literally died.
Like we literally burned her body yesterday.
I guess.
I mean, I mean, you're still going through it.
Okay.
I swear.
If you still complain about missing mom after a week, then, then we're going to have to find a way to that you, you, uh, forget your troubles.
When you find a way to help you unleash that anger and sadness, because I know you're still coping.
Why is he yellow?
I hear the crow.
I do what you said and it looked like it bounced off.
Could the board be magical?
Yeah.
Bounced off.
What do you think?
Yes.
I've ever seen.
I'm encouraging.
I'm being a good father.
See, I heard a crow.
I heard you crow.
Where are you?
I know you're here.
I know they're not voices in my head.
I fucking knew it.
I knew it.
Get out.
I knew they weren't voices in my head.
Something else.
What?
What is it?
How could it be?
Oh, hey, chest.
Alright.
Do I get...
Oh, money.
Oh, that's true.
They could come to life.
That's so true.
Loot.
Yay.
Okay.
Gotta make sure I got every loot here.
I'm gonna run.
Okay.
Do you think so?
Maybe.
Oh, coins!
I forgot!
Look at these jars!
There's money in jars!
I'm ready to break all the jars for money!
Oh, and upgrades.
Boy, I told you to stay up there!
Boy, you never listen!
Why don't you ever listen to your father?!
Alright, let's see...
Just because you can read, doesn't mean... Oh, shit!
What the fuck?!
How dare you!
You made me melee!
Okay, nice.
That bitch made me use my hands!
Up close!
The what?
What is?
Oh, there he is!
Shoot him again!
Surely it'll work a second time!
Oh, I can't control him anymore.
He's on his own.
Oh!
Wait, he actually hit him!
I thought he was magic!
Was that a lie?
Damn, I'll never be fully proud of my son.
Alright, let's see.
I'll always find a way to be disappointed.
Where did Boy go?
Boy?
Oh, I don't like this.
They changed the music.
Press square to Sean.
Sean!
I don't know, I just thought there was loot here.
I know like this was it.
Oh shit, nice.
Good job.
Oh, there's loot.
Oh, there's no loot.
Please hurry.
Why?
Why do I need to hurry?
Wait, did I?
How do I get lost?
Jason!
Oh, it's this way.
Sean!
Jason!
Okay, but what if there's loot this way?
But you don't...
Wait!
Why?
Jason!
Don't cross the road, Jason!
Oh, he stopped.
He stopped yelling back.
Jason, stay off the road!
Atreus!
Wait, what happened?
Who did he kill?
Oh no, my chest is too thick!
I'm sorry!
I had too many gains!
I should have wore a shirt!
Now I'm gonna get in scars!
He doesn't.
He's my friend.
The boy was following my command.
Then help fix this.
Hold here, please.
Oh no!
The last of his kind in all the realm and you shoot him.
You needed food?
Target practice.
Oh, that's even worse.
I'm so, so sorry.
Keep that pressure on.
This is my third wife?
She's mine.
She should have kept a closer eye.
Will he die?
I will not let him.
You.
The arrow cut a tight way inside him.
Find both ends and hold them tightly.
Oh!
Start with the left side.
Grab it and hold.
Okay.
Now pull them together.
Line them up.
So now...
I mean, if it's the last of the kind, he's gonna die eventually.
He's gonna go... They're gonna have to go extinct.
You're a witch!
I can't finish the healing here.
My home is just beyond the trees there.
You will carry him.
He must not die.
I mean, he will eventually, right?
Good.
He seems to be staying at home for now.
He's the last of his kind.
Gray...
Thaw...
Like, how would he continue the generation?
He's not the last of his kind!
There's more pigs there!
That's literally the same pig!
That's the same pig!
He just has yellow paint!
Those are normal.
But he's magic.
Those are different pigs.
What makes them different?
He just painted one of the pigs with yellow symbols!
Look at these...
There's literally two pigs in front of us!
The yellow paint matters!
It's alright.
It's cuz he has blue eyes!
Show me your eyes, other pigs!
I need to see your... Oh, shit!
Oh, shit, that's a giant turtle.
Whoa!
Is he friendly?
That's an SSR.
That's an SSR thing.
Whoa!
I need to see those pig's eyes.
I need to know if he's actually that special.
Oh!
The turtle is like...
How does it not crush the house?
That's crazy.
Is there like a... Is the house at heart?
Oh...
Oh, he's not calm anymore.
He's freaking out!
He's freaking the fuck out!
Oh!
Oh no, he's drooling!
Do you have a husband?
Do you have a boyfriend?
Are you and Peter still together?
Hold him still before he hurts himself.
Good.
Easy.
Rest now.
I need two more things.
Fresh red root growth just behind the house.
Can you pull a cluster?
What else?
What else do we need?
I...
I know you're a god.
Not of this realm, but there's no mistaking it.
What else do we need?
He doesn't know, does he?
About your true nature?
What, he doesn't know?
That is none of your concern.
The gods of these realms don't take kindly to outsiders.
Trust me.
I know.
When they find you, and they will, they'll make things difficult.
The boy will want answers.
That will be my problem.
Whatever you're hiding, you cannot protect him forever.
But you're right.
It doesn't concern me.
I also need lamb's cress.
Do you mind?
It's a white petal flower in my garden.
Just a handful.
I'm a witness protection, ma'am.
You're not supposed to know this.
Fine.
Lamb's cress.
Alright.
We gotta collect the white petal flowers.
I thought you said quickly.
He's literally slowly dying.
How is he magical?
I don't know.
Go pick some flowers.
Why am I picking flowers?
That's what boy is for.
That's literally what boy is for.
And I'm being put on flower duty?
I'm a fucking god of war.
Alright.
What does the flower even look like?
Is it that white one over here?
Oh, that's fish.
Never mind.
That's just fish.
Sorry, it looked like flowers from a fall.
I don't do flower picking.
Flower picking is boring.
I like her.
I mean, she lives under a turtle.
You are too open with her.
We do not know if she can be trusted.
She hasn't tried to kill us.
Yet.
She needs us to heal her dying pig.
Her dying, quote unquote, magical pig.
Alright.
Let's see.
What the fuck is a white flower?
Look, from afar, those look like white flowers.
That's like...
That looks like white flowers that are on the cage.
Okay.
You can't blame me for thinking those are flowers.
Oh, there it is.
There's the white flowers.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh, I just need one?
Okay.
I mean, that's convenient.
I just need one.
Is there anything else here?
Alright, let's go give her her pig some white flowers.
her pig some white flowers.
Hello.
I'll come back with flowers.
Bacon is pretty magical.
Are you still alive?
The boy is searching.
Perhaps he could use help.
Please, the salve is nothing without both...
Oh my god!
Then tell me to do it instead of giving it to the boy!
Apparently he can't see color either!
Apparently he's fucking color blind.
Boy, where did the boy go?
Where the fuck did the boy go?
What?
Where is he?
Oh, there he is!
Was that the red roots?
You dropped your knife.
Little boy.
We lost the only thing your mother had left.
Clearly, I miss your mom more than you.
Alright, return to the witch.
Witch, witch, witch.
Create your magic healing potion for your dying pig.
I'm not angry.
I'm just disappointed in you.
What?
What do you want me to do?
This mark will hide you from...
those who might make your journey difficult.
Wait, we shot him in the first place.
Yeah, why is she rewarding us?
She marked us.
Now we're hers.
Now we're magical too.
Oh my god.
We're gonna be magical as well.
Yeah, but we caused him to die.
There's a shortcut below the house that leads safely out of these woods.
Follow this path down.
Then head towards daylight.
And we're just like the pig.
Will we see you again?
Boy, she's like so much older.
Now get out of here.
Oh, boy.
Come, boy.
You need girls your own age, boy.
This underground passage...
The compass is displayed and point towards your...
Oh my god, we finally have a map!
...and take this.
You can use it to orient yourself and navigate the world.
It will always steer you towards your goals.
Oh my god, it only took three hours!
But we got a map!
We got...
We got a compass!
Oh, thank god!
We already had a map, but we have a compass now!
Thank fucking god.
Wait, what?
Where are we supposed to go?
Oh, shit!
What the fuck is that?
What is that?
Oh, okay.
Alright, get over here.
I like how I found...
I was like, yeah, I can finally know where to go!
And I'm like, where do I go?
What is that?
That's where they're hiding in a building?
Nightmares.
Yeah.
What?
Want me to tell me...
I started having nightmares, I was embarrassed but she said they were another part of life and that sometimes there was beauty in the horror.
She always saw the upside of everything, even those creepy little floating eye monsters.
They're named after an older creature called a mare that sits on your chest while you sleep and feeds off your fear.
Nightmares.
They are.
I don't remember which.
I wish I could ask you.
How do I get that out?
That's weird.
What is that?
Alright.
Let's get rid of that jar first coin.
Get over here.
Um, so we're supposed to go there, so that means I go to the other side.
Alright, nice.
Where does this go?
Oh!
Oh, I fucking knew it.
I fucking knew it.
Get in that ocean!
Hahahahaha!
Moo.
Oh!
But I am a god!
Oh, nope, nope, nope, okay.
Um...
Oh, loot!
Nice.
More loot for me!
Wait, what do I do with this?
Do I just push it out?
I guess I'll just push it out.
Hey, loot!
Give me a sec.
I gotta push it out.
What if I can push it into the ocean?
Into the water you go!
Goodbye!
Yeah.
What is under the surface?
There's like...
There's the... there's the shrine thingy there.
Got another mask.
Oops!
That's an app, didn't it?
What?
Oh, yeah?
Use your arrow!
Clearly, it's not your fucking tool!
Hahahahaha!
Don't be a smartass, boy!
Don't be a god damn smartass!
Hahahahaha!
Okay, clearly... clearly we can't go that way yet.
Uh, I guess we go this... we go back this way.
I didn't teach you to be... to talk back to your elders.
Uh, Fidelis, thank you in the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
If two witches watch two watches, which witch would watch which witch?
Oh, I fucked it up at the end.
Which watch?
Hahahahaha!
I was so confident, too.
Is there anything in here?
Over where?
The boat?
I can see the boat!
Okay...
Wait, there's a... there's a chest here!
How do I get to that chest?
There was a time I thought I'd never leave a house.
Not even my own bed.
You were not to blame for your sickness!
Oh, I know.
I guess I'm just saying...
This was great!
Can I perch here?
What is this stuff here?
Can I come from here?
Well, I need a dock.
Where the fuck is a dock?
I don't think there is a dock here.
Oh, I'll be back later?
Okay...
Okay, I'll go this way then.
Alright, off we go.
Off we go to the lands.
Through the compass that the witch gave us.
Follow the compass maker.
I really like this game so far.
I actually really enjoy it.
I like the story and the battle.
How do you know?
Do you not smell it?
Do you not smell the sea?
Oh sorry, you were a house baby for a long time.
We kept you, you were like a bubble baby.
A bubble boy.
We kept you in that bubble for so fucking long.
And then when your mom died, I was like, oh no.
I guess I'll have to make you touch grass for once.
Lake of nines, oh no.
I never thought you'd listen when mother spoke of the gods.
I seldom did.
Did she speak of one who could feel no pain?
Oh, that sounds like Baldur.
Oh, that's Baldur?
An Aesir god, son of Odin and Free.
And Odin is king.
That's right.
Why do you ask?
I thought, oh, Baldur's dead already.
This has more...
Okay, I've like read so much about like mythology.
That I've like, all my mythology has like, like blurred together.
What is that?
So like, I blurred it with like, Marvel Baldur.
Because in Marvel Baldur, they killed him.
So like, I'm not, I don't remember if like, they all, he was also supposed to be dead too.
Like, he's supposed to die.
Unless that's before he was supposed to die.
Go to the middle of the lake.
But I want to explore the corners.
It's like a puzzle.
Is that the middle of the lake?
Is that it?
I don't like this.
I think I see something.
Just sitting there in the middle of the lake.
Yeah.
Oh, that's it.
That's the thing.
What's that?
What is that?
Okay.
I see rooms there.
And it's just...
I don't...
I can't quite make it out.
I might...
Read.
Boy, read.
This is literally your only job.
It reads, Sacrifice your arms to the center of the water.
Awaken again the cradle of the world.
What?
Throw our weapons into the water?
Guess that won't be a problem for you.
Are you gonna do it?
Wait, am I actually going to throw my weapon?
Oh!
How did I do that with so much confidence?
Like, now what would I use?
Is that the snake?
Oh!
Is that the world serpent?
He's going to eat the world!
Oh, shit!
Wait, I thought this was Ragnarok, not...
Because I kill him!
I know this!
This is, like, iconic!
This is an iconic fight scene!
Oh, shit!
It speaks?
Yeah!
Mom said he's friendly!
What is it saying?
I don't know!
Oh, he's friendly?
Mom said he's friendly.
Do not be afraid!
That was amazing!
Mom said he's friendly.
Wait!
There's a sugar boy over there!
See that?
And there's a statue of Thor!
Except, I can see a lot more of him now.
The water dropped, and the serpent rose.
Don't worry, he doesn't bite.
And there's the mountain!
Look it!
That building leads from the foot of the mountain to that golden temple.
Wait, where did he go?
It was all just under the surface.
Except for the statue.
Good thing, huh?
There's even a dock.
There, next to the flag.
What the fuck?
Oh, there he is!
What is he doing there?
Wait, I see you.
What is he doing?
Is he just chilling?
What the fuck is...
Oh, he's just sleeping!
He's just sleepy, guys.
He's eepy.
He's literally just fucking sleeping.
Okay.
I wanted to, like, see what he's doing, but, like, hey, there's, like, an area here.
That's good.
He's like, alright, time to eep outside of the water.
That's where we live here, right?
Why else would it take me here?
Wait, what the fuck is that?
Oh, shit!
What the fuck?
What the...
What the fuck is...
Okay.
He fucking just slapped me.
Oh, he fucking literally slaps me.
I couldn't knock the fuck out.
Holy shit.
I was not ready for that.
The slap of death.
Well, that's cool.
He's literally called the World Serpent.
Of course he's fucking big.
Be not afraid.
Alright, we're not going back there.
We're not...
I thought I was so strong.
I realized I wasn't as strong as I thought I was.
Chat?
Wait, where the fuck is the...
Am I...
I'm rowing away from the dock right now.
Alright, it's this way.
It's this way.
Is that the dock?
This has to be the dock.
Yeah.
Alright.
Nice.
I acquired XP.
I don't know what I got.
Oh, okay.
Abandon ship.
Alright.
I found a ship head.
I saw a crow flying.
Is this the way to the mountain?
It would seem.
If it isn't the bearded beaver, it is sexy.
Bruh.
I got something for you too.
Bruh?
Well, he's tiny now.
None of your fucking business.
Now get in here.
I got something for you.
And don't go making pig eyes at my spot.
I saw it bro.
Well, he's tiny now.
Okay.
What do you think he wants?
To test our patience.
When word gets out about my new shop, folks will finally come out of hiding.
They'll be clawing all over each other just to catch a whiff of me.
You watch.
Oh, what does he have?
Wait, can I like...
Okay.
No, that doesn't work.
All right.
What do you have for me, Brock?
Catch.
Oh.
The pile of rocks there.
With that key of Yggdrasil, you can open a magic door to the branches of the world.
What?
A shortcut between the realms.
Oh.
Have you ever seen that?
I don't see them out in the world.
Use it to get back to me quick.
But it's only one way.
Straight back here and nowhere else.
And whatever you do, never, never, ever, never, ever throw yourself over the edge of the path.
Lest you want death.
Oh, it's fast travel.
Oh.
Okay.
I don't know how it can be upgraded by shop.
Press upgrade.
Okay.
Upgrade an armor to improve its stats.
I don't have stuff for that.
Reduce this.
You don't need upgrades.
Talisman of...
Gain a burst of health.
I don't have enough of that.
Nope.
Okay.
Enchantments.
Oh.
I can enchant stuff.
Nope.
Okay.
You don't need that.
Is it really worth it, guys?
To like...
Oh.
Wait.
Cool down.
What am I crafting?
Axe.
Pommel.
Oh.
I should get that.
We did war.
Strength.
Luck.
Runic.
Strength.
Cool down.
Should I get?
Okay.
What should I get for my pommel, guys?
Do not upgrade.
What?
Number three.
The curved runic.
Which one should I...
I throw a lot.
Yeah.
Three?
Should I get the curved runic handle?
Can't blend on any success.
Oh.
Position throw.
Yeah.
I should.
You're right.
I do throw a lot.
Yeah.
Okay.
Equip.
Nice.
All right.
We got that.
Fine.
The boy gets an upgrade.
Reduces the charge.
Oh.
New talent.
Bow skills.
Oh.
I guess.
All right.
Bow or quiver.
Chat.
He gets one upgrade.
I feel a little gener...
Boo.
Someone said bow.
Chat was like, boo.
No.
You can't do both.
It's only one.
I'm only allowing one.
You got to pick one.
Chat.
He only deserves one upgrade.
All right.
I'll give them the bow.
Boy.
Don't be a fool.
Don't waste my efforts.
So you're sticking around for grains of wisdom?
Yeah.
Sure.
What do you have?
No.
Okay.
All right.
I was waiting for some wisdom.
Okay.
That's the one that I got.
Do I have any new enchantments that I can put on?
No.
Okay.
Oh.
Bless you.
I have skills.
Can I afford new skills now?
Oh.
I can.
After landing, weak points press triangle during the flash to recall and cause next throw to min...
Oh.
That's cool.
What does it look like?
Okay.
I'm going to get that.
I have just enough.
Yeah.
All in.
You'll get your upgrade soon.
It's one day, boy.
What's this?
This is the fast travel, right?
Oh.
I see.
Where can I go though?
Is that it?
Where the fuck is...
Where...
I can't go anywhere else.
I can't.
All right.
Can't really go anywhere else.
I see.
Boom.
But what if I...
I charge it.
No.
That's not it.
All right.
Let's go.
Nowhere for now.
Yeah.
I know there is a crow.
I saw him.
I saw him flying.
I saw that green bastard flying around as if he owns the place.
There he is.
See I told you.
I knew I saw him!
That's fucking right.
Government spies.
What?
Look, I'm doing something very important right now.
Okay, it will work.
Okay, maybe like... Okay, never mind.
Never mind.
Clearly, I was not paying attention.
I was not paying attention, guys.
Wait, what the fuck?
He, like, regenerated.
Little does he know, it doesn't matter.
Alright, here we go again.
Alright.
Don't worry.
I will hit this.
There has to be an easier way!
Okay.
Alright.
Let's see.
I know the pattern.
Are you fucking kidding?
Okay, I'm gonna get closer.
Alright.
Here we go, here we go.
This is the pattern.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I will get this!
It cannot be impossible!
Wait, there's a chest here.
It can't be impossible.
There's no way.
Boy!
Shoot him!
Shoot him, boy!
I will prove you wrong.
There has to be a way.
No, there's no way.
There's no way it's impossible.
I will time the...
I will time this perfectly.
Okay, wait.
But what if I, like, hit here?
Okay.
Boy!
Here, this is it!
This is it!
I can feel it.
Okay.
No, no, no.
This is it!
This is right here.
Okay, I timed it incorrectly.
This is it!
Right here!
I timed it incorrectly!
Are you fucking...
Fuck this!
Fuck this bird!
God damn it!
Okay, we're gonna...
We're gonna...
We're gonna go downstairs.
We're gonna go...
There's another crow?
How did I miss another spy?
There's a crow here?
I don't see no crow.
That's a seagull, you idiots.
Where's that fucking other crow?
That tried to fuck with me.
Okay.
I'm gonna get... I'm gonna get there.
I'm gonna fucking row my boat over there.
It's the last thing I do.
Stupid crows.
Stupid government spy drones.
Wait, what's that over there?
Is that Doc over there?
I can't tell.
I'm gonna go this way first.
I wish we could have gone on a trip like this with Mother.
All right, here you go.
All right, one...
Wait, what?
Oh shit.
Get down.
What the fuck?
I thought you were dead!
Get down!
All right, boy.
This is time.
Show yourself.
Show that you're good at this.
All right, let's see.
Where is it?
Oh, there's a...
There's a thing there.
Okay.
What?
Do I need to...
Boy?
What?
What do I have to do?
Oh!
What?
Okay, now I know!
Guys, now I know.
Guys, I'm learning.
I thought I could just break it!
I thought I could just break it.
I'm a god!
I should be strong enough!
That...
I should be strong enough to break those.
I'm a fucking god.
Read.
Oh, a treasure map.
Hunter's Kingdom.
Find the location.
Oh no, I missed it.
What was it?
Where was it?
Hunter's Kingdom.
Is this?
Where the fuck is it?
Is it in the map?
Oh no.
Where's the Hunter's Kingdom shit?
Where?
It's above me?
Oh.
Oh, okay.
How do I get out of here?
Exit.
Oh, okay.
It's above me?
Where?
Codex.
Journey.
Oh, there it is.
I came to this kingdom to...
I leave this offering in memory.
All I find was death and sorrow.
I leave this offering in memory of those who suffered in the Dwarf King's quest for glory.
If he had...
Okay, where is that?
Where the fuck is that?
Uh...
Alright, guys.
Point on the map where it is.
Yeah.
YouTube, please.
Uh...
Now guys, point at the map where that is.
Everybody.
Can I break that?
No.
Wait, how the fuck do I break this then?
How do I break that?
Clearly this is breakable.
Does that get rid of that?
Alright.
Can I shoot it from here?
Alright, this is it.
We're closer now.
We're closer.
How?
I can't look high enough.
How do I kill you?
Oh my god.
Okay, here.
Let's see.
I will kill this fucking bird.
I need to time this correctly.
There we go.
God damn it!
How do I kill you?
You fucking flying rat!
This goddamn flying rat.
This goddamn stupid...
Oh, right here, right here.
This is it.
This is the golden area.
Alright.
Oh my god.
I don't know!
I don't have depth perception!
I can't tell!
I can't tell that it's closer now!
I don't have depth perception!
Oh my god.
I can't tell that it's closer now!
Right here, right here, right here.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh my god, we did it.
We fucking did it.
Holy shit.
Is there a way to get up here?
What's that sound?
You hear that?
Yeah.
Is there a way to get up here?
We fucking did it.
I can't believe it.
Or is that for later?
Later?
Okay, let's leave.
All right, we'll go back.
The government can't find me now.
Oh shit, that made me so tired.
I'm so tired after that.
That was fucking terrible.
Haha.
Oh shit, that's the portal people.
That's the portal people.
Sounds... fun?
Do you remember any?
Hm.
There was one that concerned the hair and the tortoise.
Enough.
I'm not gonna touch that.
Watch the hole again.
Wings, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Quality may vary.
Viewers are discussing Dodoki's battle with a crow enemy.
Giving advice such as aiming higher and using patience.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Fuck that crow.
Don't fuck the crow, but fuck that crow.
Alright, let's see.
Oh, there's a chest.
Oh, boy, read.
Boom.
Alright, gotta grab some loot first.
Alright, boy, read.
It's time.
Rico, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You missed almost as many shots as I got.
You played Apex.
Boy, what's the point of bringing you up here?
You can't read, boy.
Literally, your job was to read.
How do you fuck that up?
That was your entire career.
Oh, it's just loot.
Wait, I'm back here.
Wait, how did my boat get here?
What the fuck?
How did my boat get here?
Oh, is this a second boat?
There's more than one boats?
Oh, my God.
Wait, I can have more than one boat?
That's absolute crazy.
I got loot.
What's over here?
Is this another boat?
Oh!
It is something.
What's this?
What's this, boy?
Look out, tower.
Is this where I was supposed to...
Oh!
This is a sh...
Oh, this would...
This would have been so much easier to kill.
I could have done it there.
There's the shortcut that we don't need.
I could have fucking...
I could have killed the crow right there.
Well, I found it now.
Let's go.
Whoa.
Whoa!
What was that?
What was...
Yeah, good question.
Oh, okay.
It's gone.
I thought, you know...
I legitimately thought that there'd be...
Oh, shit.
Okay.
We should not let you regenerate.
All right.
Get over here.
Phew!
All right.
Nice.
Read.
I still can't read these.
Oh, my God.
What's the point?
You can't read anything.
Oh, my God.
What did your mother taught you?
I still can't read these.
All right.
Read.
Read this, then.
Another one.
Look.
It's the World Serpent.
He's so much bigger than I imagined.
Oh, look.
He bit Thor.
Or will bite him.
Look.
Oh.
What the fuck is that?
That's not Thor.
That...
Oh, my God.
I don't think that's Thor.
All right.
Let's see here.
Maybe the only one big enough to be a son.
I could have fit.
Where the fuck is...
That's not Thor.
It's...
Oh, my God.
This is...
Where the fuck is this dead?
Where the fuck is that?
Let's see.
Oh.
We can't do this yet.
Nope.
We're not strong enough.
Let's see.
What is that?
It smells awful.
I don't think we can touch it.
Can I destroy it?
Oh.
I can.
New lesson.
Uh...
Looks like he had a huge fight.
Oh, wait.
No.
What?
It's different.
Journal doesn't say what the journal is supposed to say.
Assume I can't get that yet.
And wait.
Yep.
Oh.
I knew it.
All right.
Shit.
That's not what I'm trying to aim for.
All right.
We don't get past this until we're back here.
Whoa.
There's stuff here, right?
Oh, no.
Yo, that's the climb.
Oh, but there's stuff here though.
Oh, what?
Okay, I have to be directly off...
Oh, shit!
Is he gonna fight us?
Oh, he is!
Oh, what the f- Get back here.
That's right.
That's right!
Get out!
The worms there.
They're called Tazel Worms.
Encounter more of these exotic beasts.
Okay.
The Tazel Worms...
Oh, fuck.
That's not what I wanna do.
Alright, open up.
I can't open...
What the fuck?
What kind of lock is that?
If I can just stab it...
I like how...
I like how it...
doesn't matter?
And I can just...
stab it?
Like, I thought that's pretty funny.
I was like, what's the point if I can just stab it?
Oh.
Wait,
then where does this go?
Oh, this is like...
This is like the other way...
Is this like the head...
back here?
Where does this go?
I just wanna be sure.
Okay, yeah, this goes back here.
Okay.
I was just curious where this went.
Alright.
Okay.
Now we know.
Now we know!
Wonder why...
Oh, it's a magic knife.
Okay.
That makes more sense.
I was just like...
What kind of fucking lock is that?
If I can just stab the lock and it'll be fine.
I guess because she's like a magi...
She was a magic person too, so...
Alright, here we go.
Alright.
Give me back my magic axe.
And then off we go.
Whoa!
We discovered...
Fruit Hills!
Whoa.
Sure is foggy here.
Oh?
Yeah, come on.
It's...
Another door.
Should we...?
No.
It is of no consequence.
He's a person.
How did you come by that axe?
That is my concern.
Oh, that's his other...
The Korpo brother!
I know that blade.
It was one of ours, but...
Yeah, he looks Korpo.
He looks...
I can't.
See the woman we made it for.
I was...
Well, I am quite fond of her.
And I would be somewhat displeased if it turns out that you did something to her.
Wait, why is he in me blue?
It was my mother's.
She left it to father before she died.
Face dead?
I'm very, very sorry to hear that.
She was a fierce warrior.
And a good woman.
Oh.
Yeah, I fucked her.
I will make improvements to the axe.
But nobody asked you to.
Well, it's true, but...
But knowing your mother, she would have insisted I repair that act of vandalism perpetrated against her axe by my...
Oh.
I knew it.
You are Brock's brother.
The other half of the brand's here.
Wait, what kind of upgrade does he do?
Why is he not blue?
Though my talents are vastly superior.
No boast.
Swear to Freya.
Do not undo his work.
Is Freya a giant woman?
Look at this axe.
This axe is huge.
Can you put it down over there?
That handle is...
No.
Filthy.
Okay, then.
I'll just...
I will just...
God, I wish she was.
Is that dried blood?
What are you...
What are you working on?
That.
I call it the Sky Mover.
Just up that mountain waits a treasure trove of rare resources.
Once I mine it, I'll need a way to bring it all down.
And you know how to fix it?
Not even a little.
Wait, so what does he do?
Why is his upgrades different?
Oh.
I could use a distraction.
Resurrection stones giving revived Kratos from death.
Press to enter to buy the section of the shop.
Okay.
Press X.
Uh...
Small press 12 while Kratos dies.
Cells.
Each is to resurrect him and join only one resurrection.
If I use it?
Is it gone forever?
Or like, is it like one time per...
per fight?
Is it gone forever if I use it once?
Oh, okay.
Then what's the point?
Like...
What's the point?
Okay.
Uh...
Okay, that's the palm...
I can upgrade it.
Um...
It's a consumable.
I see.
I can upgrade my axe.
Still no...
Talisman.
Pa...
You're still crafting me the same thing.
So how are you better than my...
than your brother?
Yes, my young man.
Alright, you know what?
You know what?
Let's give him a little something.
One upgrade per area, boy.
So you get your quiver upgrade now.
You did it.
You get to have your quiver upgrade.
Okay, let's... I want to upgrade.
Oh, luck of eight?
Ooh!
Talisman?
Wait, I can... Oh wait, never mind.
What's this?
Luck of ages?
Or gain a burst of health?
Oh, that gives me nothing.
Sorry.
Oh wait, no.
Defense?
Defense and luck.
No, defense and luck is good.
I was going to say I was going to replace it, but I was like, wait, never mind.
It actually gives me good shit.
Okay.
Oh, level two.
Not enough XP.
Increase the damage?
All right.
All right, guys.
We're going to call it here.
I realized I streamed for four hours today, so we're going to call it here.
Oh!
Oh, my gosh.
That was a really good game.
I really enjoyed it a lot.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, I had a great time.
It actually has been... it's been a really fun game so far.
And I'm definitely... I'm definitely looking forward... looking forward to playing more later.
But I had so much fun.
Yeah, I really want to finish this in the future.
I definitely do.
So we'll definitely have a part two next week.
But yeah, let me go to yeehaw.
Yeehaw.
Oh, my God.
I'm so tired.
I didn't realize how long I've been streaming.
I'm so tired now.
Let me make sure you're not dead on my screen.
Yeah.
I did a little stretching before I call it.
But thank you, everybody, for coming.
I really appreciate it, everybody.
I hope you guys enjoyed watching today.
Because usually I don't stream for this long.
So it was really fun.
It's been really fun playing it so far.
I definitely enjoyed the story and the gameplay so far.
I've been enjoying using my axe as a gun.
It's been very fun.
I don't know.
What can I say?
I enjoyed the ranged combat.
The ranged combat has been pretty interesting so far.
But yes, we are going to call it here.
Tomorrow is my rest day.
Because I will be at Anime Revolution in Vancouver, Canada.
I'll be doing a...
I think a concert and a meet and greet there.
I think Saturday is the panel.
But yes, I guess I'll see you guys there if you're coming to Anime Revolution.
You guys can leave gifts and letters there during the meet and greet and the concert.
For those who are going there for Mint as well.
You can leave gifts and letters for Mint as well.
And they will be sending those over to her at the concert.
So if you guys have any gifts or letters to Mint.
I think she's going to tweet about that later.
We just found out that we could.
I think like yesterday or today.
But I think she'll tweet about it.
Tweet about it later today.
But yes, you can leave gifts and letters to her as well.
At the concert.
But yes, I'm going to call it here everybody.
Sorry for no after chat.
I need to rest my voice tomorrow.
But as always everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me.
Head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.